Nice.
Ah, ja, ja.
So.
Gucken wir mal, ob Twitch schon gecheckt hat, dass der Stream on ist.
Sieht nicht so aus.
Twitch ist da teilweise nicht so geschwind.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass Twitch manchmal...
Jetzt, ah, jetzt ist es am Start, okay.
Man sieht das immer, wenn auf einmal im Chat gleichzeitig was gepostet wird.
Dann weißt du, jetzt hat es Twitch gecheckt, weil die Leute brauchen ungefähr gleich lang...
So, aufzuhören.
Es ist manchmal merkwürdig.
Manchmal braucht das zwei Sekunden, manchmal braucht das drei Minuten oder so.
Komisch.
Ah, ja.
Discord hat es gecheckt, ja, siehst du?
Aber Discord checkt es erst, wenn es Twitch gecheckt hat.
Das dauert manchmal ein bisschen.
Also man sieht es ja.
Sie pinnen jetzt zwei Minuten on und Discord...
Jetzt hat Twitch schon zwei Minuten gebraucht, quasi, bis der Discord das gecheckt hat.
Ich hatte übrigens gestern Abend noch eine Idee.
Wir haben ja gestern fünf Stunden...
Warte mal, ich mache mal kurz den Resident Sleeper...
Ne, ne, ich will mich gerne selbst angucken.
Übrigens, wisst ihr was richtig bescheuert ist?
Dass man jetzt hier teilweise auf den Namen draufklicken muss, dass man Videos sieht und sowas.
Dass man draufklicken muss?
Ja, ja.
Guck hier, jetzt ist...
Ach, guck mal, jetzt haben sie es wieder geschafft, dass Videos hier angezeigt werden, okay.
Also wir haben ja gestern fünfeinhalb Stunden ESP32 programmiert.
Denk mal, die einen oder anderen waren vielleicht dabei.
SGD.
IQ ist durch, ist jetzt nicht, ich habe ganz wenig geguckt, diesmal nur.
Aber ich habe es ja schon gesagt, dass mich das jetzt halt so extrem überkorrekt sind und unter Chat gesperrt ist.
Das interessiert mich das nicht mehr so.
Ich hatte nämlich hierzu gestern, was wir gestern gemacht haben, also eine richtig gute Idee, gestern Abend.
Und zwar, wir könnten für das Update, was wir machen, wir könnten auch so ein minimalen Webinterface bauen.
Dass man auch wie Normalsterbliche das Update über den Browser hochladen kann und nicht irgendwie per Curl über die Kommandozeile das machen muss.
Also, Stream sich selbst schauen.
Ne, das machen wir vielleicht am Mittag.
Wie gesagt, ich wollte am Mittag ja eh weitermachen mit dem T-Display.
Aber wir könnten, wir bauen glaube ich so ein minimalen Webinterface.
So gut wie einfach das Thumbnail für das Wort von gestern, das ist echt.
Warum? Was habe ich jetzt gar nicht gesehen?
Max, ruhig, ruhig.
Er ist...
Das ist leider nicht das Thumbnail.
Das Thumbnail ist das, aber das hier wäre das bessere Thumbnail gewesen.
Ja, das kommen wir, da bauen wir am Mittag nämlich vielleicht ein Webinterface dazu, dass man so ein Upload-Button hat.
Wie richtige PP gerade über das Webinterface.
Ja, naja, wie gesagt, ich habe ja eh gesagt, ich lade dann zumindest den Code für den Updater auf GitHub hoch.
Und ich glaube, die meisten benutzen sowas lieber über den Browser zum Firmware hochladen, als jetzt unbedingt über Curl.
Dann einfach noch so einen MD5-Zoom-Befehl für die Checksum und sowas.
Schon mal Fall Guys gespielt?
Nö, das ist ein Game, was mich jetzt überhaupt nicht anspricht, wo ich auch nicht gerne zugucke.
Es gibt Spiele, da gucke ich gerne zu, die ich nicht spiele, zum Beispiel Valorant.
Da gucke ich ganz gerne ab und zu mal zu.
Oder CS, spiele ich ja auch nicht mehr, großartig.
Aber Fall Guys finde ich weder zum Zugucken noch irgendwie spricht mich das großartig an.
Hey Leute, MonkaS.
Monak.
Monak S, warum?
Ich finde es eigentlich ganz gut, also zum Zugucken, zum Spielen, kein Schimmer.
Eins muss man denen aber echt mal lassen.
Und hier mal, guckt, Twitch, Games.
Äh, Directory, nicht Games.
Äh, gut, das ist ja gerade der übelste Hype.
Guck mal, der Kram hat allen Ernstes mehr Zuschauer wie Warzone und Fortnite, Alter.
Lull.
Ja, aber ich vermute mal Fall Guys.
Also, entweder sie machen dieses richtig Big Brain, dass die irgendwelche Kooperationen mit allen anderen bekannten Games starten, was das dann in dem Game irgendwie gibt.
Äh, oder aber in einem Monat interessiert das kein Mensch mehr.
Mal gucken.
Also, gibt's die zwei Möglichkeiten, denke ich.
C4 Ducky, Twitch Prime, dankeschön.
Excellent Subscription.
Massive Brainsub.
Pures Streamerloch, weiß ich nicht.
Äh, Streamer-Sommerloch.
Ähm, genau, also man muss ihnen ja schon mal sagen.
Guck mal hier.
Also, dafür, dass es ein neues Game ist, ohne dass da irgendwie sonderlich viel jetzt noch gemacht wird, gerade.
Also, jetzt irgendwie an Promotion-Geschichten und sonst was, außer die üblichen Sachen.
Es reicht schon, dass das ein Game ist von einem Hersteller, wo die Leute wissen, dass es nicht wie in Battlefield oder Overwatch morgen vorbei mit Support, ja.
Also, Overwatch ist ja Support schon mehr oder weniger Sparflamme seit zwei Jahren.
Weiß ich auch nicht, was da mit Blizzard los ist.
Und, äh, gut, Battlefield.
Battlefield 5 hat es ja eh erledigt.
Ja, ne?
Guck mal, wo ist denn Overwatch eigentlich gerade?
Erzähl mal, ja, wo ist es denn?
Ah, hier.
Ah, Wahnsinn.
Immer noch 13.000.
Wahrscheinlich, weil es einen Streamer mit 5K gibt oder so, hm?
Ja.
Ha, fast.
Weil ansonsten hat Overwatch nix, wenn da nicht einer der großen Streams so am Start ist.
Ah ja.
Ja, und es sind auch fast, das stimmt, es sind fast nur noch Koreaner.
Aber selbst in Korea wird es kaum noch gespielt.
Ich find's, ich find's witzig, seit die umgezogen sind.
Das muss ich mir jetzt angucken.
Man kann angeblich mittlerweile...
Man kann angeblich Custom-Roms mittlerweile, Custom-Software mittlerweile auf 2DS machen.
Und das find ich äußerst spannend, denn ich hab noch ein 2DS rumfliegen.
Moin, TH.
Ist das in...
Tribolon, 10 Monate.
Ich dachte, du hast gestern schon gesubbt.
Hast du entsubbt, um wieder neu zu subben.
Wie viel für die 10 Monate?
Huge Subscription.
Erstmal kurz ein bisschen kleiner machen, das Ganze.
Ja, also da bin ich echt mal gespannt drauf, was der hier erzählt.
Ansonsten, ich hab, ich hab paar, paar Random-Videos mal aufgemacht, die ganz, ganz interessant angehört haben, was wir uns halt angucken können.
Ob wir da alle packen, weiß ich nicht, müssen wir mal gucken.
Äh, irgendein Minimal-PC-Bild, auf irgendeinem komischen, das sah ganz merkwürdig aus, auf irgendeinem komischen...
What the fuck?
Ich mein, das ist ein komisches Gehäuse.
Müssen wir mal gucken, was da am Ende rauskommt.
Äh, Flappy Bird RTX On.
Keine Ahnung, ob das was taugt.
Ähm, irgendwie...
Dr. Disrespect, neutralen 15.000 Dollar-PC-Hand.
Ich frag mich allen Ernstes, wie man auf einen neutralen 15.000 Dollar-PC kommt.
Ich mein, ein 15.000 Dollar-PC ist schon ziemlich schwer.
Generell alles über einem 5.000 Dollar-PC ist schon für den Desktop-Bereich schwer.
Also, du musst dann schon, du musst dann schon Sachen einbauen, die absolut unsinnig sind.
Das ist...
Ne, also sprich...
Also, mit 5.000...
Mit 5.000 Dollar, da kannst du dir zwei...
Sogar eine SLI 2080 Ti oder 3080 Ti, wenn's dann rauskommt, einbauen.
Warum ist Max eigentlich von YouTube zu Twitch gewechselt?
Ich bin doch gar nicht gewechselt.
Mein Channel gibt's doch immer noch.
Ich hab noch nie Livestreams auf YouTube gemacht, weil Livestreaming auf YouTube sackt.
Außer meines Dr. Disrespect, dem in 30 Milliarden Leute zu gucken.
Und außerdem mag ich YouTube als Streaming-Plattform nicht.
Und Dr. Disrespect ist ja auch nur da, weil ihn der für Twitch gewandt hat.
Gibt's dazu eigentlich irgendwas Neues?
Gibt's dazu irgendwelche...
Irgendwelche Sachen?
Irgendwelche Sachen, wo jetzt rausgekommen ist?
Warum?
Weil, da hast du nichts mehr von gehört.
Außer, dass Twitch absolut nichts sagt.
Dass es irgendwie so Bigbrain-Leute wie den Slasher gibt, der sagt, ja, ich weiß es, aber ich sag's nicht.
Und dann hast du doch Dr. Disrespect, der sagt, er weiß es selber nicht.
Komisch.
Sehr merkwürdig, sehr merkwürdig.
Bin mal gespannt, was da rauskommt.
Ich hoffe ja, dass so Verhandlungen in den USA irgendwie public sind.
Und die sich jetzt irgendwie noch verklagen und dass man da irgendwie was rausbekommt.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, was der dazu sagt.
Wir haben schon lange kein Fortunet-Video mehr geguckt.
Ich mein, nachdem wir jetzt ja Modern Warfare Remastered bekommen haben, Modern Warfare 2 Remastered,
mal gucken, wie MW3 dagegen aussieht.
Irgendein Kurzgesagt-Video, mal gucken.
Ein neues Elektro-Boom-Video haben wir noch.
Was haben wir sonst noch hier?
Battlefield Top Plays.
Homelab-Tour.
Da kann ich ein bisschen über das...
Rack und Zeug von anderen Leuten lästern.
Das ist immer gut.
Da muss ich mein eigenes Zeug nicht aufräumen.
Ob das was taugt, weiß ich.
Mal schauen.
Übrigens, wisst ihr, was ich letztens gesehen habe?
Das da.
Es kann sein, dass...
Ich glaube, jetzt lacht mich nicht aus, Chat.
Ich glaube, das habe ich bei Chip gesehen.
Ich weiß auch nicht, wie ich zu Chip gekommen bin.
Könnte ich gleich noch bei der PC-Welt als nächstes gucken oder so.
Es kann sein, dass diese Sache hier defaultmäßig eingeschaltet...
Also, bei mir war die Sache defaultmäßig eingeschaltet.
Und wenn man Pech hat, steht das so.
Und in dieser Kombination...
Wenn das in dieser Kombination steht,
dann schickt man selbst an andere Leute im Internet Updates,
um die...
Gute Quelle, ja.
Aber in dem Fall hatten sie recht.
Dann schickt man an anderen Leute im Internet Updates,
um die Microsoft-Server zu entlasten.
Das will man natürlich nicht.
Das will man nicht.
Ich soll die Maschine selbst ausliefern, ja.
Was haben wir hier sonst noch so?
Top 10 Programmierideen für...
Na, das ist mir heute zu anstrengend.
Die Frage ist einfach beantwortet.
Das Video müssen wir uns eigentlich gar nicht angucken.
Warum Netflix jetzt auch schlechte Shows macht.
Ganz einfach, weil sie Geld bringt.
Netflix setzt jetzt neulich vermehrt auf Reality-TV.
Naja, ich sag mal Anglercamp, ja.
Oder Angelcamp, wie auch immer das hieß.
Ähm, weil es Geld bringt.
Weil warum...
Das ist die offensichtlichste Antwort, Alter.
Okay, wir gucken uns jetzt aber mal an, wie man
äh, Homebrew, also so Custom-Software
auf dem 2DS installieren kann.
Da bin ich echt mal gespannt drauf.
Weil ich hab noch ein 2DS rumfliegen.
Irgendwo, in irgendeiner Ecke liegt der 2DS rum.
Den hab ich mir damals gekauft.
Hab ich da nicht sogar ein Video zu gemacht?
War es ein 2DS oder ein 3DS?
Ah, 3DS.
Ah, fuck.
Dann hab ich...
Boah, nein, da kann ich das ja gar nicht installieren.
Ich hab...
Ich hab mir den damals nämlich aus Australien bestellt.
Weil, lustigerweise, Nintendo 2014 auch noch irgendwelche Region-Log-Geschiss drin hat,
was totaler Schwachsinn war, weil...
Ne?
Also, warum macht man 2014 irgendwie...
Naja, aber es ist Nintendo.
Die sind bei allem 10 Jahre später und dann kriegen sie es trotzdem nicht gescheit hin.
Das ist gar kein...
Moment.
Das ist gar kein 2DS.
Vielleicht...
Wenn wir Glück haben, geht das vielleicht auch mit einem 3DS?
Wahrscheinlich nicht, ja.
Ja, fuck.
Das geht ja gar nicht.
Oh, Hand-Leak.
Hand-Reveal, oder?
Oh, ne, da geht das ja gar nicht.
Naja, zumindest Big Brain, wie ich war.
Ich hab mir das damals ganz neu...
Ähm...
Weil ich...
Weil ich irgendwas spielen wollte.
Weil ich, glaub ich, Spirit...
Was?
Spirit Tracks?
Irgendwas.
Irgendwas wollte ich unbedingt spielen.
Ähm...
Und da hab ich mir den aus Australien damals bestellt.
Und...
Ähm...
Direkt aus Australien importiert.
Wahrscheinlich für viel zu viel Geld.
Und dann...
Hatt ich den da.
Hab den eingerichtet.
WLAN angemacht.
Sieht man ja auch hier.
WLAN eingerichtet.
Und danach hab ich ihn...
Nie wieder angehabt.
Ich hab den nach...
Ich hab den importiert aus Australien, weil ich unbedingt irgendwas spielen wollte.
Und nach dem ersten Eindruck-Video...
Hab ich nie wieder eingeschaltet.
Also richtig Low-Brain eigentlich.
Ich hab das dann auch nie gespielt, was ich spielen wollte.
Ach, ne.
A Link Between Worlds war das, was ich spielen wollte.
Genau.
Das hab ich noch original verpackt hier liegen.
Wobei, ne, stimmt gar nicht.
Das hab ich gar nicht mehr original verpackt hier liegen.
Das hab ich inklusive nem, nem, nem...
Bowser-Amiibo.
Hab ich das mal, äh...
In nem Speedrun-Event als Preis...
Ge...
Gedonated.
Hab ich gar nicht mehr.
So.
Also.
Gucken wir mal.
Ach, trotzdem.
Vielleicht geht's ja auch für ein 3DS XL.
Homebrew sollte auch gehen.
Ja, ich glaub, der ist sogar neuer als der, den ich da gezeigt hab, ne?
Die haben doch danach noch ein 2DS rausgekauft.
Weil die Leute irgendwie von 3D so abgeschreckt waren.
Was merkwürdig ist, weil man konnte 3D beim 3DS einfach ausschalten.
2017, only one month after the release of the Nintendo Switch,
while many consumers felt that the 3DS line's end of life had arrived,
Nintendo doubled down on the 3DS line
and randomly announced a new handheld,
known as the new Nintendo 2DS XL.
Priced at $149.99 US,
the 2DS XL takes the new 3DS XL and removes some features.
But with the added performance boost of the new XL line,
meant that the 2DS XL is a significant boost in performance over the earliest slate model,
the Nintendo 2DS.
Ja gut, das wird wahrscheinlich mehr oder weniger der 3DS sein, den ich auch hab,
ohne 3D.
Von der Hardware.
The Nintendo 3DS Lifespan has been going strong for over 9 years,
selling over 75 million units...
Aber jetzt ist's vorbei.
Also jetzt ist's vorbei mit dem DS.
Also, ich hab jetzt bei den letzten Nintendo-Sachen...
Okay, ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich hab nur Zusammenfassungen geguckt,
ich hab die letzten Nintendo, gab's ja auch nicht so viele Directs und Sachen mehr,
aber da wurde nichts mehr zum 3DS gezeigt, oder?
Oder fällt von euch jemand irgendwie ein, ob Nintendo was noch zum 3DS gezeigt hat?
Also meines Erachtens kam da eigentlich nichts mehr, es kam nur noch Switch-Zeugs.
... across all product lines.
But it's 2020, and it's fair to say that the 3DS product line days are numbered.
The 2DS XL in 2020,
is the only handheld available in stores.
And it's still being manufactured.
But that may change quickly.
You see, Nintendo have slashed the price of the Nintendo New 2DS XL to 99 US Dollars.
And I suspect...
2DS XL.
Haha!
9,90 Dollar!
Nicht in Deutschland, Alter!
She baited.
Gibt's das vielleicht woanders günstiger?
Tja.
Falsch gehabt.
YouTube Money, Max, ist auch was?
Ach nee, geht gar nicht.
An mich.
Jaja.
... that it will be discontinued by year end.
Ich bin ja ultra werbefreundlich mit dem, was ich mache, genau.
Das ist so.
Also ich glaube, die einzigen, die aktuell bei mir irgendwie Werbung machen könnten,
wäre so ein China-PCB-Hersteller.
Da müsste ich dann einmal im Stream sagen,
und wenn ihr super billige eigene Boards machen wollt,
dann geht zu PCBWay oder irgendwas.
... it's still available.
And at 99 Dollars for a brand new Nintendo New 2DS XL,
it makes for a compelling handheld to pick up,
to mod for homebrew and emulators.
Also, wenn mich, wenn mich, wenn mich AliExpress oder Banggood,
immer, der Name von dem Shop, der macht mich jedes Mal fertig,
ich wünsch das ja,
aber wenn mich AliExpress und Banggood sponsern würden,
ey, das is easy, easy life.
... a Nintendo New 2DS XL from Walmart for 99 Dollars.
Now, these little systems make amazing little homebrew and emulation devices.
And we're going to show you how to mod one of these things.
Ja, mach hinne. Zeig her.
... and show you the capabilities of a 2DS XL
and just how good they are for emulation purposes.
For 99 Dollars, this thing is an absolute awesome little device.
Hopp, hopp.
Today's video is brought to you by Ray...
Oh Gott.
...
... on the channel, we reviewed homebrew on the Nintendo 2DS.
The Slate device was great as a modded system,
but it struggled with some of the more difficult features.
...
mehr geht. By the way, was wir auch nochmal im Stream machen müssen, ist die PS Vita Flaschen.
Wenn ich die irgendwo finde, irgendwo habe ich sie noch. Das ist ja auch so ein Ding,
was ich mir gekauft habe mit zwei Games und dann irgendwie einmal gespielt und nie wieder
angefasst sind. Ach stimmt, was ist denn da drin? Da ist ja eine richtig ordentlich CPU drin im 2DS,
wusste ich gar nicht. Das ist ja gar kein totaler Müll im Vergleich zum ersten DS. Im ersten DS war
ja absolut keck triple U, was da drin war. Dass da überhaupt Sachen drauf gelaufen sind, hat mich
immer beeindruckt.
Das ist gar nicht so schlecht. Ich meine, es ist immerhin um ein viel viel vielfaches schneller
als der ESP32, auf dem wir gestern rumgewurstelt haben. Ist Max Robostimme nur bei mir? Kann ich
dir gleich sagen. Ja, ist nur bei dir. Ich habe es gerade in der Vorschau angehört.
Also ich gucke gerade in der Vorschau. Ich höre mir das gerade in der Vorschau an. Ich hab da,
ich hab da ganz normalen ganz normalen Sound und wenn man sich hier guckt,
hier ist auch Lautstärke okay und hier ist auch nichts übersteuert oder sonstwas.
Es ist so geil, dass wir ein Drittel von dem Video gebraucht haben, bis es mit Homebrew
überhaupt losgeht.
All in all, wie bei jedem anderen System in der 3DS-Linie, ist das neue 2DS XL mit dem
Nintendo DS-Prozessor abhängig.
Und die Beziehung des zweiten ARM 9 Prozessors ist genutzt, um das zu gestalten.
Du kannst jeden alten DS-Spiel auf diesem Handheld gut laden und spielen.
Aber in DS-Mode zu spielen, lässt dich in eine Sandbox zu, die weggelegt ist.
Eine Schleife für viele Menschen, die die 3DS oder 2DS XL modifizieren wollen, ist, etwas
wie die R4i-Goal-Karte zu benutzen.
Oh!
Den, den, den, so einen habe ich auch noch.
So einen habe ich noch für den DS.
Allerdings, ich hatte einen anderen, ich hatte keinen F4,
ich hatte einen, falls das noch jemand kennt, einen
Cyclo DS oder so hieß das Ding.
Das war richtig Big Brain, das Teil.
Das war, sah aus wie eine SD-Karte,
war aber, war aber für, für
Custom, Custom ROMs
und Firmware und da konntest
du dann quasi beliebig viele Games für den DS
drauf machen. Und,
was auch cool war, der hatte noch
sogar den, der 3DS hat ja vorne
noch einen Game Boy Advance Slot.
Du konntest sogar da drüber Game Boy Advance
Spiele emulieren, äh, nicht emulieren, äh,
faken quasi.
Das geht da drin nicht.
Das glaube ich nicht, dass das funktioniert.
Ja gut, das ist klar, das ist
klar, das ist ja auch nur für DS-Games.
Hahaha
Flasht das Image vom 2DS
einfach auf deinen Staubsauger.
Ich glaube die CPU,
ich glaube die CPU-Architektur waren
mehr oder weniger die gleiche, oder?
Wart mal, wart mal. Ich muss mal kurz
gucken, was für CPUs in meinem Staubsauger sind.
Schau, wir schauen mal kurz nach.
Wartet mal kurz.
Wir müssen mal kurz gucken, was für CPUs bei mir
im Staubsauger sind.
Pater O'Haley, 6 Monate. Dankeschön.
Excellent Subscription.
Wartet mal, wartet mal. Ich muss, ich muss schnell
nachschauen, das, das interessiert mich jetzt.
Also ich meine nicht, dass wir das überhaupt flashen können, aber
äh, mich interessiert wirklich, was
für CPUs, ob da, ob ich die ähnlichen
CPUs in meinem Staubsauger drin hab.
Äh,
es
Ah ne, nicht als Max, als Ruth.
Staubsauger, antworten?
Ach du Scheiße, was ist das?
Äh
Was hatte ich denn da für ein Passwort?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 wahrscheinlich,
so wie ich mich kenne.
Ne, Moment.
Moment.
Moment, kriegen wir gleich.
Access SSH,
was ist, was ist Standardpasswort?
Cleaner.
Cleaner, genau, genau, cleaner.
Der Chat, der Chat ist immer,
also ich muss echt sagen, mein Chat ist wirklich
massive brained. Die sind da teilweise
Zeug, wo ich denke, das ist
absolut Nischenkram, wissen die.
Ja.
Cleaner. Ja.
Excellent. Oh, oh.
Leaked.
Ähm.
Dass man damit irgendwas anfangen kann.
CPU-Info.
Und Proc-CPU-Info.
Okay, in meinem
Staubsauger sind AMV7.
Okay. AMV7. Nicht, nicht, aber fast.
Fast.
Ja.
Excellent. Okay.
Also, die CPU-Architektur
wäre
zumindest schon mal nicht, äh,
also was heißt eigentlich, die CPUs
wären zumindest schon mal so, dass ich nicht
2DS auf meinen Staubsauger
flashen könnte.
Aber immerhin, ich meine,
ernsthaft, wer hat schon einen Staubsauger
mit SSH-Root-Zugang?
Oh, was ich jetzt angucken kann, ja.
Äh, MarkLDMM.
Fünf Monate. Dankeschön für den Sub.
...
Also, dein Staubsauger hat keine CPU,
das denkst du.
Die meisten Geräte haben mittlerweile
irgendeine Art von Microcontroller drin.
Was ist das für ein Staubsauger?
Das ist ein...
So einer.
Ein Showme...
Was, die man tatsächlich Showme ausspricht,
das muss ich ja auch mich schon öfters belehren lassen.
Ein Showme S...
Roborock S50.
Allerdings musst du aufpassen,
weil die, äh, ganz neuen Versionen davon sind wohl nicht mehr so einfach zu flashen mit Custom Firmware.
Also ich hab hier das hier als...
Ich hab das hier als Firmware drauf.
Custom Firmware.
Da gibt's auch fertige Images, die kann man einfach flashen.
Und da hast du...
Bekommst du dieses...
Dieses...
Bekommst du dieses Webinterface auf dem Staubsauger.
Äh...
Hallo?
What the fuck?
Was hab ich denn geschrieben?
Ach, maupunkmaus, maupunkhaus.
So, ähm, da kriegst du ein Webinterface.
Und kannst hier drüber dann Staubsauger steuern.
Wofür Custom Firmware...
Ja, dass du zum Beispiel ein Webinterface bekommst, wo du Staubsauger drüber steuern kannst.
Das geht mit der Standard Firmware nicht.
Mit der Standard Firmware hast du nur die offizielle China-App.
Du hast nur die...
Du hast nur die offizielle China-App.
Übrigens, man kann mit der...
Mit dem Webinterface, das ist wirklich ganz praktisch.
Das ist übrigens nicht...
Das ist wirklich die aktuellste Version.
Ich muss das mal updaten.
Was ganz praktisch ist, du siehst, was er macht.
Also sprich, du siehst die Karte beispielsweise vom Wohnzimmer, wo er rumdüst.
Du kannst hier verschiedene Zonen vergeben.
Du kannst manuelle Steuerung machen.
Und du kannst ein paar Sachen hier noch einstellen.
Aber das Praktischste ist, Zonen einstellen.
Habe ich jetzt keine eingestellt.
Da kann man zum Beispiel sagen, okay, ähm...
Keine Ahnung, mal angenommen, mal angenommen, man würde vom Sofa...
Hier sitzt mein Sofa.
Mal angenommen, man würde immer auf dem Sofa sitzen und Chips futtern.
Was ich nicht mache.
Ich benutze das Wohnzimmer eigentlich...
So gut wie gar nicht.
Mal angenommen, man würde immer hier auf dem Sofa sitzen und Chips futtern.
Dann könnte ich hier eine Region definieren und sagen, ey, äh, Chipszone.
Und dann würde ich sagen, clean Chipszone.
Und dann würde er dann in die Zone fahren, Chips wegmachen und wieder andocken automatisch.
Exzellent.
Genau, und man kann ja noch mehrere Sachen einstellen.
Übrigens, wenn ich finden drücke, dann schreit er durch die Wohnung, hallo, hier bin ich.
Da ist keiner.
Ich habe nämlich auch ein deutsches Sprachpack dafür gefunden.
So, genau.
Wo man gerade beim Thema...
Ähm, Custom, Custom Firmware sind.
Es gibt übrigens komplett Custom, es gibt, es gibt Tools, da kann man ein komplett customizedes Sprachpaket für den Staubsauger erstellen.
Also, man könnte, man könnte zum Beispiel irgendwie ein Halo Sprachpaket erstellen, wo dann irgendwie der Master Chief irgendwas erzählt oder so.
Alles was man will, ja.
Selfmade Eyes, vier Monate.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
So, gucken wir mal weiter.
Ja, ist running 11.3.
So, ich habe hier ein Sprachpaket für den Staubsauger.
Ich habe den Guide für 11.3 gefolgt, der mich zu einem Ersatz, der Seedminer genannt wird.
Dieser Prozess betrifft das Dumping der DSI-Wear-Exporte durch einen Ersatz der DSI-Wear-Management-Sektion in der Settings-Applikation.
Aber um das zu funktionieren, ist die System-Encryption-Key notwendig, um das DSI-Wear-File zu bauen.
Und für das musst du Seedminer benutzen, eine Applikation, die die Key für dich generiert.
Das braucht eine kraftvolle GPU.
In anderen Worten, du wirst deinen Seedminer benutzen.
Aber sobald das alles fertig ist, kannst du den Ersatz erfolgen.
Also nur, dass ich das jetzt verstehe.
Die dumpen irgendwelche Sachen vom 3DS.
Und um das entschlüsseln zu können, wo dann die weiteren Sachen drin sind,
muss man mit seiner Grafikkarte irgendwelche Brute-Force-Angriffe machen.
Also sprich, man muss irgendwelche Brute-Force-Hash-Geschichten Brute-Forcen für seinen 3DS.
Und dann kann man weitermachen.
Habe ich das jetzt richtig verstanden?
Wie findet man raus, ob es leicht flashbar ist?
Du musst...
Da musst du mal bei denen auf GitHub gucken.
Die haben im Wiki stehen, ab welcher Firmware-Version es geht, ab welcher es nicht.
Oder vielleicht kann man mittlerweile auch alle flashen.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Musst du mal ein bisschen gucken.
Gucken wir heute das neue How-To...
Oh, das gibt ein neues How-To-Twitch-Chat.
Das müssen wir euch sofort aufmachen.
Das ist top.
How-To-Twitch-Chat.
Und dann gucken wir gleich das DS.
Hey, Hugh.
Ja, ja, ja.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Es gibt ein neues How-To-Twitch-Chat.
Excellent.
PP...
Jawoll, das gucken wir.
Jetzt gucken wir erstmal das Video fertig.
Ja, sag mal ja.
Gut.
Ein N64 sollte eigentlich mit so einer fetten CPU ordentlich funktionieren.
Ich meine, das steigt.
Das steigt extrem.
Also ich meine...
Sprich, umso leistungsfähiger...
Würde ich mal so über den Daumen gepeilt sagen.
Umso leistungsfähiger die Ursprungs-Hardware,
umso viel mehr leistungsfähiger das Emulator-Ding.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es dazu irgendwelche Studien gibt.
Also ich würde sagen, du brauchst mindestens das Dreifache.
Ich sage das jetzt einfach mal so.
Also ohne, dass ich da großartige Ahnung hätte.
Du brauchst mindestens die Dreifache Rechenleistung,
die im Ursprungssystem, wenn es emuliert ist.
Außer, wenn es gibt irgendwelche Abkürzungen.
Also zum Beispiel,
solltest du so gut wie nichts emulieren müssen.
Also sprich, sollten sie es irgendwann mal auf die Reihe kriegen,
da eine PS4 zu emulieren,
was ja schon mehr oder weniger ein x86-Ding ist,
dann ist es wahrscheinlich kein Ding.
Dann ist es wahrscheinlich kein großartiges Problem.
Aber ansonsten denke ich mal,
du brauchst ungefähr die Dreifache Leistung,
wie das Ursprungssystem hat.
Was bei den alten Konsolen,
sagen wir mal, bis zum N64,
bei PS2 und Gamecube hört es dann schon langsam auf.
Was noch recht überschaubar ist,
die Dreifache Leistung.
Oder Dreifache bis Vierfache Leistung,
je nachdem, wie kompliziert das zu emulieren ist.
Aber bei Gamecube geht es dann mittlerweile auch ziemlich gut.
Aber ab da wird es dann schon schwierig.
Also wie gesagt, N64 war so lahm,
im Vergleich zu heute,
zur Hardware,
dass es bestimmt auch ganz gut auf dem 2DS läuft.
Das stimmt, Leute.
Ihr könnt die N64 auf einem 2DS emulieren,
mit einem neuen 2DS XL,
dank der tollen Arbeit von Master Fires
und dem Emulator, der den Daedalus X64 genannt wird.
Das ist ein Port der PS Vita Version,
der noch in sehr viel früherer Phase ist,
oder der experimentellen Phase.
Aber was hier schon sehr versprochen ist,
mit einem Arm-Dynarex-Kompiler,
Safe-State-Support,
der Fähigkeit, Aspekt-Ratios zu ändern,
und viel mehr.
Dieser Emulator ist absolut großartig.
Ich habe Super Mario 64 getestet,
Mario Kart 64,
Star Fox 64,
N64,
Xbox Zero X,
und während der Emulator manchmal hinkt und stuttert,
ist es ein beeindruckendes Erlebnis.
Und ich kann nicht warten,
bis wir sehen, wo die Entwicklung uns bringt.
Anmerkend, dass die N64-Emulation
in vielen Systemseiten gezwungen ist,
sieht man einen Rennen auf einem 99 Dollar neuen 2DS XL
eine absolute Freude.
Ich meine, das ist doch ganz brauchbar.
Quake 3 ist ein Quake 3 und Quake 3 Arena Port
für den Nintendo 3DS.
Okay, okay, also,
ich glaube Quake 3
mit den Analog-Sticks,
oder generell,
ist nicht,
ist nicht sonderlich spaßig.
Ich hätte damit,
ich hätte damit ein Problem,
weil ich bin ja einer der wenigen,
die Inverted spielen.
Wie ist das bei euch?
Analog-Sticks,
Inverted oder normal?
Die meisten Leute,
hier,
quaken mich immer aus,
wenn ich sage, ich spiele Inverted.
Twinkover spielt auch Inverted.
Ja, ich glaube, wir sind da wirklich die
Ausnahme.
Ich weiß auch nicht,
wo das herkommt,
aber ich kann instinktiv besser Inverted spielen
als normal.
Deswegen hoffe ich jedes Mal,
dass die nicht auf die Idee kommen,
dass es jetzt normal wird,
dass es in Spielen diese Option nicht mehr gibt.
Inverted, okay.
Also, ich muss sagen,
es sind so ungefähr 90% normal
und 10% Inverted.
Ja, und ich hoffe,
die haben da eine Option für,
dass man das einstellen kann.
Ich bin auch ein Fan von 3DS-Ports,
und es ist eines der besten 3DS-Ports auf dem System.
Die Playstation-1-Emulation ist ein bisschen
ein Mixed Bag,
aber es ist wert,
mir darüber zu sprechen.
Ja, ich glaube,
es ist eine gute Option,
wenn man von der oberen Seite des Touchpads
auf die untere Seite des Touchpads
bewegt.
Was macht dein Browser dann?
Geht der runter,
oder geht der hoch?
Also, das habe ich so,
dass der runter geht.
Also, dann habe ich wahrscheinlich mal,
also, mein Touchpad ist nicht Inverted.
Weil, wenn man von oben nach unten
scrollt,
dann wird das Touchpad
in den Untergrund
gespeichert.
Also, wenn man von oben nach unten
scrollt,
weil, wenn man von oben nach unten scrollt,
dass er dann hoch geht,
das ist irgendwie komisch.
Läuft auch ReactOS drauf?
Nee, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Es sei denn,
es gibt irgendwie ein ARM11-Reactor.
Nee, nee, nee, garantiert nicht.
Ich äh, ich habe aber auch
ein Gamepad,
aber ich habe noch nicht
so ein Gamepad.
Also, ganz klar,
es liegt nicht auf dem testifiedischen
System,
sondern auf dem Internet.
Also ich habe
ein PC,
und den kann ich auch
auf der Internetseite
meinen.
Also, wir haben
noch nicht
so viel
Half-Life struggled on the Nintendo 2DS, but with the added RAM and processing power of
the new 2DS XL, it's a great experience.
Max versucht sich ein Half-Life-Sound.
Oh, es ist wenigstens auch die internationale Version, wo schön gesplattert wird.
Die hatten ja Half-Life 1, die haben einen riesen Aufwand gemacht damals, um das in Deutschland
rausbringen zu können.
Die haben alle Soldaten durch Roboter ersetzt, inklusive neue Voice-Sachen und neue Animationen,
wie das hier.
Dass sie Schrauben verlieren und sowas.
Hast du eine Meinung zu externen mobilen Monitoren?
Ich kenne nur dieses eine Ding mit den ausklappbaren Seitenmonitoren.
Ne, das habe ich mir noch nie angeguckt.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es sowas gibt.
Das ist quasi ein Monitor, den du neben deinem Notebook stellen kannst, oder wie?
Eigentlich keine schlechte Idee.
Wusste ich gar nicht, dass es das gibt.
Ich kenne nur dieses Notebook, wo es links und rechts zwei ausklappbare Bildschirme
gibt.
Genau, und die Wissenschaftler und Wachmänner haben sich auf den Boden gesetzt und den
Kopf geschüttelt, wenn du sie gekillt hast, in der deutschen Half-Life-Version.
Ja, wenn man wirklich viel unterwegs ist, stelle ich mir das sinnig vor, ja, klar.
Notebook-Display, generell, Notebook, schön und gut, aber es geht nix über eine ordentliche
Maus, eine ordentliche Tastatur und wenn man dann noch einen ordentlichen Bildschirm hat,
ist das natürlich richtig gut.
Also mit Notebook, mit Notebook-Tastatur und Notebook.
Trackpad, Touchpad, Trackpoint bei IBM, was auch immer, da kannst du mal ein paar Minuten
was mitmachen, aber wenn du da wirklich ernsthaft was mitmachen musst, kriege ich Anfälle.
Also zumindest eine Maus brauche ich.
Also Notebook-Tastatur geht ja noch, aber Notebook-Maus ist echt, power on video über
USB-C, machen die schon, machen die schon USB-4 mit PCI-Express über USB oder, oder
ist das noch?
Ist das noch irgendwie was, was eigenes?
Ach, USB-4 soll erst 2021, ja, ich blick da bei USB mittlerweile echt nicht mehr durch.
Ich habe ja ein Video zu USB-4 gemacht, wo ich mich ein bisschen lustig, ich habe ja auch
ein bisschen lustig gemacht habe über den Standard und die Benahmung der ganzen USB-Geschichten,
das war Ende letzten Jahres, deswegen habe ich jetzt eigentlich gedacht, dass USB-4 mittlerweile
ein Jahr später in manchen Geräten so experimentell drin ist, aber anscheinend nicht, zumal jetzt
ja auch lustigerweise, also ich habe mich ja hier nicht grundlos drüber lustig gemacht,
das ist schon teilweise echt bescheuert, was die hier mit USB-4 gemacht haben.
So, und jetzt kam Intel und hat gesagt, okay, USB-4, das USB-Gremium, USB-Forum sind Idioten,
also haben sie nicht offiziell gesagt, aber inoffiziell, weil ursprünglich war es so,
Intel hatte Thunderbolt, äh, ne Moment, äh, war es Thunder, ne, warte mal, doch, oder?
Thunderbolt hieß das von Intel, Thunderbolt, genau, so, und Intel hat quasi ihr Thunderbolt
mehr oder weniger übergeben.
An das USB-Forum, dass sie USB-4 machen können, also die meisten Sachen, die in USB-4 sind,
kommen, kommen von Thunderbolt.
So, allerdings hat es, haben dies die USB-Spezifizierungsleute so wir gemacht, weil die USB-Spezifikation
ist irgendwie 280 Seiten lang oder so, und jetzt kam Intel und hat gesagt, wisst ihr was,
ihr könnt uns mal, wir machen jetzt ein eigenes USB-4, wir machen ein Thunderbolt 4 und da
machen wir einfach alles, was verwirrend ist, Pflicht und fertig, also sprich das, was das
USB-Forum hätte auch machen sollen.
So, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Äh, ah, hier.
AEC-3DS ist ein experimenteller Amiga-Emulator für die 3DS-Linie, der noch in frühen Entwicklung
ist.
Während es Bugs hat, erwarte ich, dass sie über Zeit festgestellt werden, und dieser
Emulator zeigt große Voraussetzungen.
Und ein weiterer toller Computer-Emulator ist VICE-3DS, der klassische C64-Emulator, der
auf der Nintendo-3DS-Linie läuft.
Das virtuelle Keyboard auf der unteren Seite macht diesen einer der besseren Ports.
Es geht nicht darum, den richtigen Button zu finden, um das virtuelle Keyboard zu lokalisieren.
Es ist großartig.
Uridium und internationales Karate auf einem Handheld hat niemals gespielt und gespielt
besser.
Retro-Arch auf der Nintendo-3DS läuft, wie man es auch erwarten würde.
Ich habe den Nintendo Game Boy, Sega Mega Drive und Super Nintendo getestet, da läuft
ein Retro-Arch drauf, das ist ja cool.
... und einige Street Fighter Alpha 2 Arcade-Games mit Final Burn Alpha, und sie haben alle gut
gespielt.
Das einzige Problem, das ich hier wirklich hatte, war die Zeit, um die Libretro-Cores
zu laden.
Normalerweise dauert es über 20 Sekunden oder mehr, aber wenn du alle spielst, sieht
alles gut aus.
Also, in Abschluss...
Ja gut, 20 Sekunden brauchen ja die meisten Spiele schon, bis sie im Hauptmenü sind.
... viel mehr zu Homebrew auf der Nintendo-2DS-XL, dass ich es hier nicht beobachten kann.
Es gibt viele Utilität, Homebrew-Games, Applikationen und mehr, und ich habe nur die Oberfläche
auf das Mögliche gesperrt.
Und das ist das, was die 3DS-Szene so großartig macht.
Es ist sehr lebendig und gut im Jahr 2020, und mit einem 99 Dollar neuen 2DS-XL, macht
es für eine Kommunikation von 3DS-Szenen sehr viel Spaß.
Und ich kann es definitiv empfehlen.
Also, da habt ihr es, das ist die Nintendo-2DS-XL.
Und wenn ihr das Video gemacht habt...
Das muss ich ausprobieren.
Das muss ich unbedingt ausprobieren.
Das schreibe ich mir gleich auf für den Stream.
Ähm...
3DS...
XL...
Homebrew...
Flaschen...
Car...
Irgendwie sowas.
Mal gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Äh...
Also...
Ich blick...
Wie gesagt, ich blick beim USB-4 auch nicht mehr genau durch.
Also die...
Die...
Es gibt...
Jetzt...
Wen es genau interessiert,
wenn es genau interessiert,
kann sich mal ein Video dazu angucken.
Merken kann man sich den Scheiß nicht.
Ich habe irgendwo eine Tabelle, wo ich das einblende.
So, ich reacte jetzt mal zu meinem eigenen Video.
Da können wir uns mal angucken, wie das ist.
Hallo Jungs und Mädels, hier ist...
Ne, das mache ich nicht, das ist doof.
Wo habe ich denn die Tabelle?
Übrigens, hier ist der USB-Standard.
Das sind irgendwie 569 Seiten, ist die USB-4.
Irgendwo hatte ich hier eine Tabelle, wo ich es eingeblendet habe.
Hier, genau.
Also, das ursprüngliche USB 3.0 wurde umbenannt mit USB 3.1
in USB 3.1 Gen 1 mit 5 Gigabits.
Dann gab es neu bei USB 3.1
USB 3.1 Gen 2.
Dann kam USB 3.0.
Da wurde das alte USB 3,
was vorher schon umbenannt wurde in USB 3.1 Gen 1,
wurde umbenannt in USB 3.2 Gen 1.
Das andere wurde umbenannt in USB 3.2 Gen 2.
Und das richtige USB 3.2 ist USB 3.2 Gen 2x2.
Ich weiß nicht, was bei denen im Kopf vorgeht.
So, und jetzt gibt es noch USB 4.0.
Wobei ich mir gar nicht sicher bin, wie USB 4.0 intern heißt, gerade aus dem Kopf.
Wahrscheinlich USB 4.0 Gen 3.
2.
Gen 3x2.
Ich glaube, Gen 3x2 heißt es jetzt.
USB 4.0 ist Gen 3x2.
Also, genau.
Das neue USB ist USB 4.0 Gen 3x2.
Das ist so bescheuert.
Das sind bestimmt die gleichen Leute in C++.
Das ist so bescheuert, dass man es nicht in C++-Standard machen muss, ja.
Da blickst du nicht durch.
Also wer es genau wissen will, kann sich mein Video dazu angucken.
Da habe ich das erklärt.
Merken, ganz ehrlich, merken konnte ich mir den ganzen Kram nicht.
Das ist ja, das kann sich auch echt kein Mensch merken.
Okay, also Homebrew auf dem 3DS XL, das probieren wir im Stream mal aus.
Wichtig.
Da bin ich, da bin ich wirklich sehr gespannt, ob das funktioniert.
3DS XL.
3DS XL Homebrew.
Geht das auch?
3DS Hex Guide.
Okay, anscheinend, anscheinend geht das.
Ne, new, new.
Okay, anscheinend gibt es da die Möglichkeiten zu.
Okay.
Homebrew Launcher.
Okay, anscheinend, anscheinend funktioniert das.
Anscheinend funktioniert das auf einem 3DS.
Das probieren wir im Stream aus.
Unbedingt.
Da bin ich wirklich sehr gespannt drauf.
Wie kann man sich so ein Eigentor schießen?
Ja, mit den Benamungen.
Ich weiß nicht, was mit den los ist.
Also, die WLAN-Leute machen das richtig.
Die nennen den Scheiß jetzt einfach WiFi 6.
Gut, der richtige Name für WiFi 6 ist 802.11ax.
Das USB-Gremium, also die haben jetzt gesagt, okay, 802.11ax kann sich der normale User nicht merken.
Also nennen wir es WiFi 6.
Ich finde, das ist irgendwie ein nachvollziehbarer Schritt.
Das USB-Forum macht das Umgedrehte.
Das USB-Forum hätte WiFi 6 umbenannt in 802.11ax.
Das ist, das finde ich, ist aus so Marketingtechnischer Sicht eine ganz gute Benamung.
Das kann ja, das kann ja durchaus intern und auch im Standard und in Firmware und sonst wo, kann das ja ruhig meinetwegen mit diesem Identifier funktionieren.
Mit diesem Identifier verwendet werden.
Aber man kann das, warum sollte man es nicht mit WiFi 6 vermarkten?
Ich finde, das ist für alle Beteiligten besser.
Vor allem, wenn klar ist, was genau unterstützt werden muss.
Bei USB 4 ist es ja nicht klar.
Bei USB 4 kannst du USB 4 draufschreiben, obwohl du USB 4 gar nicht unterstützt.
Also, um USB 4 draufschreiben zu können, reicht es, wenn du USB 3.2 Gen 2x2 unterstützt.
Du musst gar nicht USB 4 unterstützen.
Das ist ja der Witz.
Du kannst USB 4 draufschreiben, ohne USB 4 zu unterstützen.
Das ist halt total hängengeblieben.
Weil die wollen halt, dass sich USB 4 durchsetzt.
So, und jetzt ist Intel halt hergekommen, hat gesagt, wisst ihr was?
Die haben wortwörtlich gesagt zum USB-Forum.
Piss dich, Aldo!
Und haben gesagt, wir machen ein Thunderbolt 4.
Und scheißen auf alles, was das USB-Forum macht.
Ist aber noch ganz neu.
Aber, ja.
Wirklich, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Piss dich, Aldo!
Denen war das zu dumm.
Als gelernter Tischler verstehe ich so gar nichts.
Es versteht keiner.
Das hat nichts damit zu tun, dass du Tischler bist und wir uns vielleicht mit Technik beschäftigen den ganzen Tag.
Aber wir verstehen es auch nicht.
Also, ich habe auch keine Ahnung, was die sich da überlegt haben.
Also, das versteht niemand.
Das verstehen die doch nicht mal selbst.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass wenn du einfach im USB-Forum fragst,
ein halbes Jahr nach ihrem Standard-Meeting,
dass der Typ dann auch vor dir steht und denkt, was?
3.2 Gen 2x2?
Also, ich gehe auch davon aus, dass die gleichen Leute den C++-Standard machen, wie die.
Okay, also.
How to Twitch Chat PPE-Modes.
Jetzt wird's, jetzt...
Jetzt kriegen wir wieder was beigebracht, Chat.
Ui! Ach, ne.
I do not want to hear this nonsense right now.
Every single titty streamer on Twitch is more fun than me.
Are you su...
Oh my god, I can't.
I'm just gonna use my phone.
This is so ridiculous.
Hello, class.
I hope you're all doing well today.
I see we have some online students joining us for this class.
I'm so glad y'all could make it.
As this lesson today will be a continuation of our lesson from last class.
We'll be covering the emotes that contain...
Silly champ.
...the feels prefix.
And some miscellaneous ones...
Moment, was?
Was gucken wir uns heute an?
We'll be covering the emotes that contain the feels prefix.
And some miscellaneous ones that don't really have a group of their own.
The first emote of today will be feels okay man.
The most ideal way to use this emote is to let Chat and the streamer know of an accomplishment you've just reached.
For example, just passed 1500 subscribers on YouTube.
Feels okay man.
Another use that can just be touched on is if you are using it to thank a streamer for their streams or something that streamer did...
Ey!
Warte.
Ich hab jetzt ein paar Videos von dem Typ geguckt.
Was?
Was genau macht der eigentlich?
Ich seh immer nur Videoclips von dem.
Wo er mit anderen Streamern zusammensitzt und irgendwie denen ihre Psyche analysiert, ja?
Was wisst das eigentlich für ein Kerl?
Everything in the world is whose fault, Asriel?
Absolutely.
Besides that, from around 2017 there was a trend to type out feels okay man with the right pointing finger and the okay hand emoji.
Very prominent in Forsens Community.
To the point where when you search the copypasta...
Gut, Forsen Community ist ja auch so eine Sache für sich.
He is about 95% of the results.
And there is also this funny clip that is loosely related with the only connection being the title of the clip is the copypasta itself.
Can you make, can you make, I feel like you should at some point, you need to make a new song with, for me, with some more oomph in it.
Hey, isn't that the guy who looked at my boobs?
The next Emo we will take a look at is feelsgoodman.
Okay champ.
This Emo is the most original as you can get.
Ripped from a comic that came out in 2005 by Matt Fury.
This is basically the great, great, great grandfather of all Pepe Emos on Twitch.
For the use of this Emo, I'm sure in the past it was used to express a very happy emotion in chat...
Was, Video lauter?
Ist das zu leise?
Basically the great, great, great grandfather of all...
Okay, okay.
Ripped from a comic that came out in 2005 by Matt Fury.
This is basically the great, great, great grandfather of all Pepe Emos on Twitch.
For the use of this Emo, I'm sure in the past it was used to express a very happy emotion in chat.
War, Video lauter?
Smells giving.
Hopefully in the past it was used to express a very happy emotion in chat or on forums before
Twitch.
For the use of this Emo, I'm sure in the past it was used to express a very happy emotion in chat or on forums before Twitch.
Amaranth spornt brachte,лас zum Teilmagier遊 wens.
게임wieder.
Auch für die Momentan sei der das nome Queenimals inองsstr查 sein kannました,
ja aber mit mit ich brauche den easy clap gift mit transparent transparent
gibt kein easy clap transparent was ist das denn
warum gibt es kein warum gibt es kein easy clap transparent leute ich brauche
das und warum das ist ja kann doch nicht sein dass es das nicht gibt
exklusiv als erstes ergebnis
warum gibt es easy clap nicht transparent dann kann ich leider nicht
hinzufügen weil das sieht das sieht doof aus guck mal wenn ich das hier jetzt
nehme dann sieht das so aus wie hypers so das
ist auch doof das muss ich auch mal löschen das lösche ich nur nicht weil
ich dann meine e-mails reordern das ist und transparent sie doof aus easy
clap gift uns begibt es nicht da dann da nicht ja dass wir uns weiter
gucken
okay
is happening
also
hat
Das ist übrigens auch ein Sponsorship, wo ich komplett mitmachen würde.
Ich würde mich sofort von irgendeinem Snack-Anbieter sponsern lassen. Sofort.
Wenn da irgendeiner kommt und sagt, Max, futter im Stream unser Zeug und erzähl den Leuten, wie geil das schmeckt, würde ich sofort machen.
Unter der Voraussetzung, es schmeckt auch gut.
Weil ich habe keinen Bock, also es gibt ja kaum was Schlimmeres als ekliges Essen, was du essen musst.
Hotpockets.
Das ist das ideale E-Mail, das man schreibt.
Ich habe alle meine Verbindungen mit den Leuten verloren, also bin ich einfach sehr seltsam.
Es ist traurig, aber so ist es.
Entschuldigung?
Da habe ich sogar geguckt.
Da hat Dan erzählt, wie es so ist.
Der Weg zu einem...
Erfolgreichen, großen Streamer, wo er halt gesagt hat, okay, da macht er halt den ganzen Tag Streamen und jetzt hat er sich halt ein Büro geholt, dass er überhaupt mal noch rausgeht und ein paar Leute sieht.
Und er kennt halt nicht viele Leute.
Kommt drauf an, wie sozial man ist.
Ich habe kein Problem damit, wenn ich wenig mit Leuten zu tun habe, weil ich mag Leute allgemein nicht.
Zedge ist ein übelst dummes E-Mail.
Unfortunate.
Und feels bad man is unequivocally going to become nothing but a...
In the past, within the next few months.
Oh, my, my, of course, of course.
How could I forget Zedge?
You know what?
Since you did so well at catching my error, why don't you come up here and claim a nice reward for your awesome explanation?
Oh, really?
That is pretty pog champion.
Yeah, come on, just come a little closer.
I got it right here under my desk.
What the heck was that for?
Hey, what are you doing?
Anyways.
Die Animationen sind aber schon nice, die er macht.
Let's keep moving forward like we were before.
We were so rudely interrupted by one of your classmates.
Ah, a perfect E-Mail for what just happened.
Let's take a look at feels weird man.
When using feels weird man, it's almost as if you are basically saying, I'm not mad, just disappointed.
Weird champ.
Or whatever you chose to send that E-Mail to.
Which makes this E-Mail, in my opinion...
QYX logo.
Subscribed.
Dankeschön.
Hi, fan, subscribed.
Silenz ab.
Much more devastating to see in your chat room if you are a streamer on the receiving end of a feels weird man spam.
Because chat is basically telling you to do better because they know you can.
The next E-Mail we will be covering today is feels strong man.
This E-Mail is probably one of my favorite E-Mails solely for the message it portrays.
If anything plays that makes chat feel nostalgic, you will be sure to see this E-Mail throughout the whole thing.
The most popular song to trigger this spam would be the classic.
But other than that, if a streamer is looking back at past,
memories on stream, or something inspirational was said,
this E-Mail is also a very good choice to type in the chat room.
At the end of the day, if you can't get it, you can sit with me in your room.
Alter, warum drehen manche Leute so übelst ab?
I mean, klar, da ist es wahrscheinlich nicht mal ernst gemeint, aber ich gucke am liebsten Streams, die ich theoretisch auch im Hintergrund laufen lassen kann und Leute, die einfach random anfangen zu schreien, das kriege ich immer im Anfall.
There really isn't much explaining to do.
Let's take a look at feels birthday man.
Really, the only purpose for this E-Mail is to say happy birthday.
Let's take a look at feels birthday man. Really, the only purpose for this E-Mail is to say happy birthday.
Whether it being the streamer, or someone in chat wants to spend $30,000 to let everyone know that it's their birthday.
The next E-Mail is somewhat rare to see in the chatroom.
Let's check out feelsamazingman,
This E-Mail has someone involved from what the name suggests,
as the only time I have seen a feelsamazingman spam
Is when it's paired with either a pill emoji or some sort of food emoji.
is when it's paired with either a pill emoji or some sort of food emoji.
More often than not, it's used when drugs are referenced in the game,
or a video the streamer is watching.
The next two E-Mails have almost the same meaning,
but they are just a few tiny differences between the two.
Also ich benutze das immer, also ich benutze das und das so ungefähr synonym, also sprich, wenn irgendwas einfach hängen geblieben ist, ja.
Low Brain, Low Brain.
Es gibt heute auch ein Battlefield-Video, ja, wahrscheinlich sogar, vielleicht sogar als nächstes, ja, gibt noch, allerdings muss man gucken, ob wir das nicht schon kennen.
Du wirst manchmal sehen, dass Chat diese E-Motes spammt, und das ist nicht, um Chat runterzuholen, weil ich sicher bin, dass es eine vokale Minorität ist, die mit diesem E-Mote-Spam durchschlägt, und es wäre nicht fair, alle Chat zu blöden für ein paar Problem-User.
Für die nächsten E-Motes, werden diese ein paar Missverständnisse sein, die nicht wirklich eine Gruppe oder Präfix zu ihnen verbunden haben.
Lass uns zuerst über Coggers sprechen.
Für Coggers, ist dieses E-Mote, wenn etwas spinnt, auf dem Screen gezeigt wird.
Das ist wirklich es, es gibt keinen tieferen Sinn, und das ist, was ich denke, macht dieses E-Mote so lustig zu sehen im Chat.
Dieser nächste E-Mote war sehr populär.
Cogger, das Beste.
Ja, ja.
Weee, Hypers!
Dieses E-Mote kam raus, als das Spiel auf dem Peak war, und wir haben gesehen, dass Drake Ninja verwendet hat, als Promo für sein Album, das rausgekommen ist.
Außerdem war dieses E-Mote extrem populär in der Soda Poppins-Community, so viel so, dass er es in seinem Kanal immer noch erlaubt hat, bis heute.
Oh, okay, Klasse, danke euch alle, dass ihr heute hier seid.
Als Begründung, werdet ihr alle mit einem Film behandelt, nächste Klasse.
Es heißt, die Geschichte der YouTube- und Twitch-Wahl oder so etwas, sollte ein guter Zuschauer sein.
Ansonsten, Klasse, ich hoffe, ihr habt einen guten Rest eures Tages, und ich sehe euch nächste Klasse.
Exzellent.
Jetzt sind wir wieder ein bisschen schlauer, Leute.
Jetzt wissen wir wieder Bescheid, ja?
So.
Tains auf 14 Monate.
Ui, ui, ui, 14, das ist ja schon wirklich...
Dankeschön für 14 Monate Subscription, huge.
Übrigens, wer gestern nicht dabei war, im Stream, wir haben gestern eines der wichtigsten Sachen schlechthin programmiert.
Wir haben es geschafft, Ayaya auf einem Display anzuzeigen.
Auf einem ESP32 Microcontroller-Display.
Ganz, ist eines der wichtigsten Projekte aller Zeiten gewesen.
So.
Äh, was gucken wir als nächstes?
Battlefield, wir gucken eine Runde Battlefield.
Das ist wirklich nicht verkehrt, wir gucken echt eine Runde Battlefield.
Lining them up on Battlefield Top Place.
Wir müssen mal gucken, ob wir das nicht schon kennen.
Das ist ein bisschen älter.
Aber ich glaube, wir haben es noch nicht geguckt.
Falls wir das schon kennen, müsst ihr was sagen.
Aber meistens merke ich das ja selber.
Oh, ja, das, äh, deswegen stellt man sich auch nicht an diese mobilen Geschütze dran, weil man ist sofort tot normalerweise.
Was ist, was ist, sag mal, ist das gestellt?
Ist das gestellt?
Was ist mit denen los?
So bescheuert kann man doch nicht sein.
Sich da an die Geschütze zu stellen und, und, ach.
Was ist mit den Gegnern los?
Ist das Singleplayer-Kampagne?
Ist das, ist das...
Alter, Movement-Götter hier wieder am Start.
Deswegen sieht man in allen Spielen, gute Spieler bewegen sich ständig.
Naja, okay, das stimmt nicht ganz.
Guckt euch CS an.
Wobei, selbst in CS, in CS ist es nicht so, dass irgendwie Leute einfach mal...
...grundlos zwei Minuten in die gleiche Richtung gucken.
Aber in der Regel ist es so, gute Spieler bewegen sich ständig.
Und machen, machen ständig irgendwas.
Top Place.
I loved that intro clip.
It's so much fun when the enemies line up for you.
Did send in two clips.
The first was that incredible six-man with the M98B on Paracel.
And the second is another six-man...
In Overwatch ist man zum Beispiel die ganze Zeit sinnlos am AD-AD-Spam, weil das Movement im Spiel bescheuert ist.
...on Langkang Dam with the JNG-90.
True, 0W, ja.
Alter, wie sie sich wieder wegschneibern lassen.
Ja, aber in CS ist das Movement nicht bescheuert.
In Overwatch ist es so, dass es keine Beschleunigung gibt.
Also in Overwatch bist du Movement-mäßig von 0 auf 100.
Was ja, was prinzipiell okay ist für dich selbst, vom Spielgefühl her, aber auch für andere Spieler.
Und wenn du in Overwatch strafe links-rechts, links-rechts spammst, zappelst du halt wild hin und her.
Weil das Spiel halt Vollspeed nach links, Vollspeed nach rechts animiert.
Voll bescheuern.
Deswegen siehst du Spieler, die quasi irgendwie einfach nur überleben wollen.
Und wenn sie normal moven, keine Chance haben.
Einfach nur ein bisschen...
So, dann wirst du übelst schlecht getroffen.
Wenn du nie D.Va bist und sowas hier machst.
Ey, dich trifft keine Sau.
Richtig, richtig hängengeblieben.
Ist das Max FPS, lebt der immer noch?
Nee, nee, der lebt nicht mehr.
Hab ich schon...
Nee, den gibt's nicht mehr.
Wobei, wobei ich heute ein neues Video machen wollte.
Hab ich gestern geteasert.
Aber wenn wir heute Mittag weiter Programmier-Stream machen,
dann kann ich heute kein neues Video machen.
Weil irgendwann muss ich das machen.
Neues Video Post Champ.
Das ist seit ein paar Monaten schon Post Champ.
Gepaust Champ.
Einfach im Stream aufnehmen.
Ja, und ich muss ja immer noch Gameplay oder irgendwas zusammenschnibbeln und so.
Das kann ich nicht im Video machen.
Äh, nicht im Stream machen.
Oh, nice!
Ich mein, das ist halt übelst Glück,
dass die da sich hier
durch Collateral...
Collateralen lassen.
Besser Spot.
Wobei, noch besserer Spot ist...
Wobei, nee, das ist der gute Spot.
Vergiss, das ist der gute Spot.
Das ist der gute Spot.
Eins weiter vorne ist auch noch ein guter Spot.
Oh, wie sie da stehen,
dass sie hinkriegen.
Die müssen sich abbiegen.
、、
Ja, Battlefield 3 ist, würde ich sagen,
weniger Headglitche, und ich finde, man trifft in
Battlefield 3 die Leute, die da rausgucken, ganz gut.
Vor allem machts auch den Kopf übelst
Damage, wenn du triffst.
Generell, halt, Deckungsmovement ist
in Battlefield 3 huge.
Alter, die lassen sich ja so
heftigst wegsprayen.
Die Munition auch noch alle.
Ich hätte jetzt ehrlich gesagt, hätte ich irgendeinen Kit aufgehoben, was da rumliegt.
Okay, hier liegt gerade nichts rum, aber vorne hat was rumliegt.
Aber da musst du auch erstmal dran denken.
Alter, die lassen sich so krass wegsprayen, die Gegner. Wahnsinn.
Äh, Unrun Dead.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das nächste Battlefield wieder in der jetzigen Zeit spielt.
Gehe ich sogar mal von aus.
Zumindest irgendwas in dem Dreh jetzt.
Übrigens, MonkHS.
Wisst ihr, in welchem Jahr Battlefield 4 spielt?
Ja, Captain Peng hat recht. 2020.
Battlefield 4 spielt 2020.
Allerdings haben sie es ziemlich schlecht prädiktet.
Wir haben zwar gerade Probleme, aber andere Probleme.
Als in Battlefield 4.
Wobei ich ganz ehrlich sagen muss, mir ist Corona lieber als, ähm...
Dritter Weltkrieg mit China und den USA.
Ist mir ehrlich gesagt, ist mir Corona lieber, ja?
Moving on, we've got two clips from Dusty.
Both are gonna be using the MG4 and both are gonna be on Metro.
Some good old-fashioned spray-and-pray backrages on the meatgrinder.
Oh, da lassen sie sich wieder schön mit der LMG wegsprayen.
Habt ihr die hässliche Reflexion gesehen gerade?
Gut, nee, ist ja nicht so, als wäre das jetzt relevant, aber ist mir doch gerade aufgefallen.
Äh, manche...
Diese Battlefield-Sports sind halt teilweise echt, ja.
Also gerade Battlefield 4 auf, auf, äh, locker.
C, ist das C-Flagge?
Da sport man teilweise hinter den Gegnern.
Das, manchmal, wenn man Pech hat.
Oder, oder Glück hat, je nachdem.
Metro, was sonst? Wir haben schon lange kein Metro mehr gesehen.
Man, man kann das hart größer machen, doch, doch.
Ich mach auch kurz ein bisschen leiser.
Wenn die Metro-Boys hier weggesprayt...
Alter!
Leute, dreht euch!
Um!
Dreht euch, guckt halt mal!
Kein Bock.
Umdrehen ist overrated.
She baited.
Beste Waffe, beste Waffe im Spiel.
Also nein, die M16 ist eigentlich besser, aber mir gefällt die hier am besten.
...with the M416 before thinking about a different route into the enemy nest.
And there they are.
A big spraydown with the M416.
Oh.
Moment, Moment, ist der, was ist denn der?
Ist der, ist der?
Der ist Defender, ah!
Nice flank.
And the second clip is a Nushar-Kanal clip.
Oh, die Sniper-Turm.
Die Sniper-Turm.
...of the camper on the tower, takes his spawn beacon down and then takes his place.
But he's not up here for long as he pushes down towards the enemy players who are down below.
Der weiß genau, wenn er hier oben steht...
...wo er stehen bleibt, wird der Clip nicht genommen.
Die Posi da oben, ey.
Oh.
Boah, also dass der, dass der den Headshot gehittet hat, das war eine Mischung aus Glück und ziemlich gut geaimt.
Nicht der, der hier war auch schon gut, aber der nächste, der nächste ist wirklich gut.
Es gibt Nushar-Kanals in Battlefield...
...Battlefield 4, äh, äh, kann's sein, Battlefield 4?
Nee, nee, nee, nee, das war Battlefield 3.
Guck mal, guck mal.
Den hier jetzt, den Headshot, also das ist wirklich nicht ohne.
Also der war, also das, das ist wirklich, äh...
...Poggers.
...is his weapon of choice, sniping on Metro, you've gotta be good to make it work.
And he certainly is the original Metro-King, coming in with around two minutes of a pure demolition job on Metro.
Just destroying...
...the enemy team.
Amazing stuff.
Wann kommt wieder ein Dual-Metall...
Fuck, wie kommst du darauf jetzt?
Wir haben uns schon seit Jahren nichts mehr aufgenommen.
Also, da muss man sagen, also, das, das Aiming ist da echt on point von dem Kerl.
Also, wenn er hittet, hittet er in den Kopf.
Gut, jetzt trifft er, man kann nicht alles treffen, du kannst ja nicht alles predikten, was die Gegner machen.
Aber trotzdem, also, die, die Shots, die er hittet, sind echt krass gelesen am Anfang.
Das war ein Headshot!
Hat er irgendwie...
...only-Headshot-Mod, oder?
Was ist da los?
Okay, das war mal kein Headshot zur Abwechslung.
Oh, der war auch...
Alter!
Also, die Snipes sind wirklich nice, da kannst du nichts dran.
Wollt ihr jetzt erstmal ein 360 machen?
Oh!
Keeping it with BF3 and sniping, we've got a short clip from Maddox Gaming.
No shark can owls, the M98B, and a really accurate sniping feed.
Oh, das ganze Magazin, ey.
Das war nice.
Das war nice, ja, da gäbe ich ihm recht.
Matti's next.
Definitely check this guy out on Twitch if you're looking for some Battlefield 4 streams.
He's one of the only people that really streams Battlefield 4.
Was halt bei diesen Top-Plays-Videos immer ist, locker Metro zu 80%.
...Metro 4 these days.
It's a good one, though, this clip with the SCAR-H-Operation locken...
Sind die Gegner AFK? Ja, natürlich.
Die Gegner sind total, total, äh, halb braindead schon in solchen Clips.
Aber du brauchst halt solche Gegner, sonst kriegst du solche Clips nicht gebacken.
...a lot of that as well.
Also, the enemy players seem to be a little bit confused.
Das war ja auch damals, wenn ich irgendwelche Gameplays hoch gelernt hab mit gutem Score,
da waren halt oftmals ziemlich low-brained Gegner dabei, aber es geht nicht anders.
Du kannst nicht... Das Gegenteil ist Modern-Warfare-Matchmaking.
Es macht Spaß für keinen, ja.
Da wird getry-hardet gegen getry-hardet, geschwitzt gegen geschwitzt.
Und dann gehst du raus halt mit 25 zu 20, so.
Du brauchst ein bisschen Gegner, die verkacken.
...his movement and map knowledge really does put them at a massive disadvantage.
A great clip.
Man kann mit dem Defi in Battlefield 4 über drei Kilometer reizen.
Oh, zu spät.
Das war aber auch wieder echt...
...schade.
Und direkt danach auf dem hier.
Okay, dass er da jetzt nicht tot ist, ist halt wieder Hardcore-Pepega-Gegner.
Aber die werden schon heftig zerstört gerade.
Holst du dir das neue Black Ops?
Wahrscheinlich schon.
Aber ich geh davon aus, wenn da wieder hier Skill-Based Matchmaking am Start ist,
was wahrscheinlich so sein wird, weil das ist ja eher eine strategische Entscheidung,
wahrscheinlich ist es nicht das, was sie sich ausgedacht haben dafür,
sondern irgendwas, wo hier irgendwelche Stonksmenschen gesagt haben,
das ist gut.
Dann weiß ich nicht, wie lange der Multiplayer überhaupt macht.
Battlefield 6 soll nächstes Jahr...
...soll nächstes Jahr kommen.
Äh...
...weiß ich nicht.
Ich glaub so wirklich 100% noch keiner geäußert.
Ja, Skill-Based Match...
In Warzone, ja, es ist halt auch total offensichtlich, ne?
Wird Warzone dann geändert zu Cold War?
Ich gehe davon aus, dass Warzone quasi weiterhin Standalone bleibt.
So wie es jetzt auch ist.
Dass sie vielleicht das ein bisschen weiter noch abkoppeln von Modern Warfare.
Dass dann auch nicht mehr Modern Warfare oder so drinne steht.
Und, ähm...
...dass sie halt Contents aus mehreren Call of Duties reinbringen.
Also die werden garantiert Charaktere aus Black Ops dann in Warzone bringen.
Das macht halt einfach...bringt halt einfach Geld.
Bios? Spies?
Not too sure how to pronounce that one.
Playing on locker in the snow lane.
He's running with a riot shield out.
Maybe he's trying to block against an annoying sniper in the distance.
It's a weird tactic to be honest.
But he does have his big Type 88 LMG as a primary.
Behind the enemy players.
And he demolishes them all.
Es wird auch mal Zeit.
Weil man muss ehrlich sagen...
...Werdansk ist übelst hässlich.
Also die Map...
...also die...die...die Warzone Map ist einfach nur...
...lieblos zusammengekleistert.
Spielst du Warzone...
Ich hab relativ viel gespielt.
Bis vor einem Monat oder so.
Also mal kurzzeitig.
Ich hab mal so zwei Monate lang richtig viel gespielt.
Aber...
...irgendwie hab ich keinen Bock mehr auf das Game.
G18 das Ding ist so ein...
Okay der hätte sich auch mal umdrehen können.
Aber die G18 die haut so rein in dem Spiel.
Ja genau.
Muscle Place.
Also ich fänds halt...
...was ich halt gut finde...
...also ohne Skill-Based Matchmaking ist halt einfach...
...du hast halt auch einen Großteil der Runden...
...da läufts nicht so gut...
...aber da fährst du halt mal wieder Runden zwischendurch...
...oder halt dann die...die...die...
...Loop-Lobby schlechthin erwischt hast...
...wo du halt dann 35-1 alles zerstörst.
...
Oder wenn du dann Videos siehst, äh, Warzone-Trios und Quads-Solo-Win und solche, solche Geschichten.
Das ist alles gef... also nicht gefakt, der gewinnt das wirklich.
Das ist entweder Lobby-Klitsch, ich weiß nicht, ob das noch geht auf der PS4, wo du dann quasi Noobs nachjoinen konntest über die Liste.
Ähm, oder ob's ein Reverse-Boost-to-the-Counter ist, keine Ahnung.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall nicht legit im eigentlichen Sinne, er spielt.
Gut, dass die Claim auch so glänzt, weil du siehst das beispielsweise in Warzone, wenn du, wenn man sich mal irgendwie Huskers oder so anguckt.
Ja, denke ich kann man sagen, einer der besten Spieler in, in dem Spielmodus ist.
Ähm, der geht übelst ab, aber sogar der wird halt, sogar der stirbt jede zweite, dritte Runde oder jede dritte Runde und so, äh, die restlichen gewinnt er dann halt einfach.
Ähm, stirbt er halt random an irgendwas.
Also, das ist einfach total legendär, das Gefühl von einem einfachen Bullshit, den du nicht vorhersehen kannst.
Sei es irgendein Typ, der hinter einem Fenster rumcampt, oder irgendwas, ja.
Der, der kriegt halt einfach Teilweise richtig krass auf den Sack.
Ähm, und weil das halt einfach Sachen sind, die du nicht, die du nicht wirklich vorhersehnen, nicht so wirklich politikken kannst, die einfach
die halt einfach passieren, wo du auch nicht gegensteuern kannst, großartig.
Du kannst halt irgendwie so safe wie möglich spielen, so ne Mischung, wie der das macht, aus möglichst vielen Kills, aggressiv.
Aber
die Safe-Routen wählen, aber du kannst immer noch,
wenn du die Auswahl hast zwischen, ich laufe
jetzt den Weg und den Weg, der Weg
ist sicherer, der andere nicht, kann trotzdem da
irgendeiner liegen hinterm Fenster.
Doch, doch, Cheaters hatten wir auch schon ein paar.
Aber ich muss sagen,
es war jetzt, finde ich, nicht so
extrem, wie das
teilweise dargestellt wurde.
Genau, das stimmt,
ich glaube, das habe ich sogar gesehen im Stream,
dass da viel Glück
dabei ist, einfach drauf, wobei man
halt sagen muss, er ist halt in
einfach drauf auch ziemlich gut.
Also, sowohl wie der teilweise
mit seinen Assault Rifles die Gegner über
die halbe Map trifft und getrackt
kriegt, wenn die mit dem
Fallschirm runterspringen und sowas.
Also, der hat halt die Mechanics dabei, dass der halt
auch quasi nahezu
jedes One-on-One
und teilweise Two-on-One
auch gewinnt.
Aber trotzdem, es ist viel Glück
dabei.
Und letztlich heute, der letzte Locker-Clip von DarkFear.
Diesmal ist er etwas weiter runter, sein Team
dominiert, er hat noch einen Flagg, den er nehmen kann
und er hat den Job einfach beendet.
Aber, hätte er nicht mal wenigstens den Clip
ein bisschen heller machen können, wenn du, du siehst
gerade mal den Umriss irgendwie vom Gegner.
AEK und G18-Kombos,
ein paar Töne in diesem, als er versucht,
Echo-Objektiv zu nehmen.
Danke fürs Zuschauen dieses Episodes der Battlefield Top Plays.
Wenn du deine eigenen Clips hast, kannst du sie finden,
siehst du sie auch in der Beschreibung,
es ist battlefieldtopplays.gmail.com.
Schicke dir deine Clips mit deinem Kanal
und ich werde mein Bestes tun, sie zu verwenden,
wenn sie gut genug sind.
Danke fürs Zuschauen und ich werde dich
in der nächsten Episode sehen.
Bis zum nächsten Mal, tschüss.
ARD Text im Auftrag von FUNK
Da mussten die Azubis einmal morgens
Rundgang im Rechenzentrum machen.
Und irgendwann sind wir dazu übergegangen,
den Rechenzentrums Rundgang im Dunklen zu machen.
Weiß nicht, ob ich das schon mal erzählt habe.
Wir sind, wir haben, wir haben es quasi,
wir sind, wir haben, wir haben den Rundgang
immer im Dunklen gemacht.
Es hatte einmal den Sinn, dass man irgendwelche
Warnlämpchen besser sieht und das zweite
war, wo wir, wo wir irgendwie gesagt haben,
ja, den Eindruck haben alle, die das machen,
das hat irgendwie so weihnachtliche Stimmung.
Irgendwie hat Rechenzentrum im Dunklen hat
irgendwie weihnachtliche Stimmung, weil da
blinkt es die ganze Zeit grün, blau, orange,
rot, es hat, es hat irgendwie was weihnachtliches, ja.
Ivo B.T.W., Twitch Prime, Dankeschön.
Excellent Subscription.
Ohne um nichts zu sagen.
Ja, also ich finde, ich, ich finde,
der Anblick laufender Hardware im dunklen Raum
hat irgendwie was.
Hast du deine Ausbildung eigentlich verkürzt?
Nee, absichtlich nicht, weil ich noch ein
halbes Jahr länger erstens was lernen wollte
und zweitens das entspannte Azubi-Leben
haben wollte.
Ah, das, das hat irgendwie was weihnachtliches.
Ich finde das, wobei, bei dem blinkt ja
neulich mal so viel, im großen Rechenzentrum
ist da schon ein bisschen mehr.
Der zweite ist der Wicheltwinkler.
Zwei Monate, Dankeschön.
Subscription.
Big Brain Subscription.
Excellent.
Ah, jetzt hat er es an.
Okay, zeig mal her, was hat er denn da?
Okay, so ne 4HE-Kiste, die verdächtig ähnlich aussieht
zu meinem 4HE-Case.
Ist das das gleiche Case, was wir haben?
Moment.
Ich glaube, das ist das gleiche Case.
Nur, nur er hat, er hat vorne die Griffe dran.
Die Griffe habe ich nie installiert.
Das ist das gleiche Case, Leute.
Das ist das gleiche Case.
Oder?
Guck mal.
Das hier, der, der, der, das Fenster.
Und ich habe auch Griffe, tatsächlich.
Das ist das gleiche Case.
Ja.
Oder irgendein, der sehr gut das Case abgeklaut hat,
nachgebaut hat.
Hauptsache die Serials auf die HDD-Trace geschrieben.
Ja.
Bleibt ja nicht viel anderes übrig.
Also wenn du keine, wenn du nicht irgendwie eine Möglichkeit hast,
dass du irgendwie einen Einschub hast mit LEDs,
wo du Fehler anzeigen kannst
und du auch eine Möglichkeit hast,
diesen Fehler vom Betriebssystem zur LED zu kommunizieren,
bleibt dir ja nichts anderes übrig, ne?
Weil du nicht weißt, welche HDD sonst kaputt ist.
Also ich habe mal probiert bei meinem, wie hieß dieses Ding?
Von welchem Hersteller ist das?
Warte mal.
Muss ich grad mal gucken.
Wie heißen die nochmal?
Microserver?
Ne, ne, ne.
Moment.
Wie heißt, wie heißt dieser Hersteller nochmal?
Wie heißen, wie heißen die?
Super, ne.
Superserver?
Ne.
Relativ bekannter Hersteller, wo auch viele Leute im Heimbereich verwenden.
Na gut.
Zumindest von denen habe ich den Wechselrahmen.
Super Mikro.
Super Mikro meine ich.
Genau.
Ja, ja, ja.
Super Mikro.
Von denen habe ich den Wechselrahmen hier und der kann über S-G-P-I-O, heißt das,
Backplane, da kann man so einen Connector anschließen, so einen Kabels hier, an den Wechselrahmen
und dann braucht man halt nur noch, nur noch in Anführungsstrichen, hupp, ein Gegenstück,
zum Beispiel hier sein jeweiliger RAID Controller, der die Sachen füttern kann.
Also ich habe Glück, dass auf dem Server Mainboard, auf dem Mainboard im Server, dass da ein Anschluss für war und dass es für Linux Tools gibt, wo man das setzen kann.
Und ich habe mir damals vorgenommen, ich wollte sowas für einen Microcontroller nachbauen, wo man sowas setzen kann.
An der Backplane habe ich aber nie gemacht.
Das ist echt so eine Wissenschaft für sich, wie man LEDs an Festplatten, an Einschüben, an Backplane, wie man LEDs ansteuern kann.
Das ist auch wieder so ein Ding, so Arkane-Wissenschaft, wo keiner so genau weiß, wie es eigentlich funktioniert.
Meinst du eine Backplane für eine Festplatte? Ja.
Man sieht doch den Port, wo die Platte kaputt ist. Ja.
Aber du siehst nicht um... Ne, ne, ne, siehst du nicht. Siehst du nicht.
Du bekommst eine Meldung, keine Ahnung, äh, DEVSDF ist kaputt.
So. Du hast keine Ahnung, wenn du dir das hier anguckst, du hast keine Ahnung...
Moment, fuck, wo ist das Video jetzt hin?
Äh.
Ah, hier. Du hast keine Ahnung, SDF, was das hier, welcher Platte das entspricht.
Also sprich, wenn du eine Meldung kriegst, SDF ist kaputt, weißt du nicht.
So, das heißt, dir bleibt nichts anderes da übrig, wie zu gucken, aha, SDF hatte eine Festplatte mit der Seriennummer XY
und dann kannst du hier nach... Es sei denn, du hast halt die Möglichkeit, die LEDs zu steuern.
Was, wie gesagt, eine Wissenschaft für sich ist.
Was ITSM und Netbox... Also Netbox kenne ich, das ist so ein Webinterface.
Äh, für, für IPs und, und Hardwaregedöns und sowas.
Aber ich weiß nicht, wie dir das in Zuordnung hilft.
Ich mein, klar, du könntest natürlich... Ja, nee, nee, stimmt.
Also, ja, du könntest in Netbox reinschreiben, ähm, Server A hat SDF auf dem ersten Slot und sowas in der Richtung.
Aber da ist das mit Serials doch fast einfacher.
Oder wie würdest du das machen? Also, ich find, das ist eine sinnvolle Geschichte.
Noch besser ist natürlich, wenn man die, wenn man die LEDs irgendwie ansteuern kann.
Wobei, wie gesagt, das hab ich mal probiert, das ist eine Wissenschaft für sich.
Kannst du mir sagen, wer sich sowas anguckt?
Äh, Gott, who cares? Das, ja, frag ich mich auch, äh, so ein Schwachsinn.
Es gibt, es sind die Leute, die sich auch Berlin Tag und Nacht angucken und so.
Gut, ähm, gucken wir mal weiter.
Also, stimmt, ich wollte ja gucken, was, was hat er denn hier am Start?
Also, das ist ungefähr das gleiche Gehäuse, wie ich auch hab.
Das ist aber HDT-Kontroll...
Wenn dein RAID-Geschichte ordentlich angelegt ist, weiß man sofort, welche HDD zickt.
Nee!
Das geht nur, wenn du eine Back...
Das geht nur, wenn du einen Einschub hast mit der passenden Backplane, die erstens mal eine Error-LED hat
und zweitens du die Error-LED über deinen RAID-Controller oder über irgendwas anderes ansteuern kannst.
Aber das hat, das haben die meisten Dinger nicht, die man daheim so stehen hat.
Das haben meistens nur fertig, komplett gekaufte Server, also sprich, wenn du dir dann irgendeine Storage-Kiste kaufst,
also sprich, schon fertig...
Ein fertiges Gehäuse mit passender Hardware und sowas drin, die haben das, aber was du da im Heimbereich so hast, ist das nicht so.
Und das Ansteuern, wie gesagt, das geht meistens über SGPIO, nennt sich das, was man da so an LEDs an der Backplane hat.
Das Ansteuern ist nicht so einfach.
Das im Video ist eine Fertigkiste, ja.
Aber anscheinend nicht mit Error-LEDs.
Hätte das Ding Error-LEDs und könnte er das aus seiner Hardware setzen, dann hätte er das wahrscheinlich nicht draufgelegt.
Das kann ja auch durchaus sein, dass die Einschübe, dass die eine Error-LED haben und auch das Interface dazu,
allerdings, dass das Mainboard, der RAID-Controller, die Hardware, die er eingebaut hat in das Gehäuse,
vielleicht ist es ja nur das Gehäuse, das eben nicht kann.
Also das ist einfach, es ist schwieriger, als man denkt.
Ja, klar, wenn man im Enterprise einen fertigen Server kauft, ist klar.
Aber zum Beispiel, du kaufst dir so ein Gehäuse, ne, guck dir mal meine Kiste an hier.
Ich hab da...
Ich hab da vorne einen Wechselrahmen drin und ich hab hier einen Mainboard drin, was glücklicherweise SGPIO hat, Anschlüsse.
Das kann ich dann anschließen und steuern, okay.
Aber das überhaupt in Kombination zu finden, war schon mal gar nicht so einfach.
Und es ist leider eine Sache, die ziemlich stiefmütterlich behandelt wird.
Weil ich hab mal geguckt nach Implementierung für irgendwie ESP32 oder sowas.
Weil das wäre natürlich auch noch eine coole Variante, dass man...
...die LEDs der Backplane über einen Microcontroller steuert.
Wäre natürlich auch eine Option, weil wenn mein Mainboard und Raidcontroller das nicht können...
...der... mein Onboard-Raidcontroller kann es by the way nicht.
Ich hab's mit so einem Side-Link-Kabel versucht, das kann der nicht.
Also...
Hier, diesen Status setzen von den LEDs, das hat der halt nicht drin.
Und ich mach's jetzt über dieses Onboard-Ding, ja, aber auch mit ein bisschen Skriptlogik dahinter.
Und...
...und...
Ich hatte mir mal das Protokoll angeguckt, das ist gar nicht so kompliziert.
Und ich hatte mir schon lange mal vorgenommen, das zu versuchen mit dem ESP32 nachzubauen.
Dass man eben mit dem ESP32 quasi Festplatten-LEDs, Backplane-LEDs steuern kann.
Hab ich aber bisher nie gemacht.
Das ist auch ein bisschen aufwendiger, da müsste ich erstmal so einen Logic-Analyzer dran schließen...
...und gucken, okay, wie sieht das genau aus, was die übertragen.
und dann versuchen, das mal nachzubauen.
Machst du auch eine Stream-Idee.
Das muss ich erstmal off-stream
ausprobieren, weil ich echt
kein, legit kein Plastenschimmer habe.
Das ist auch nicht so einfach, also
ich muss mir das Protokoll erst mal genau
angucken und ich muss vor allem mitschneiden. Also sprich,
ich muss
mal eine Logic, ich hab hier so ein
Logic
Analyzer
so, da hab ich so
einen kleinen von.
Die sind echt
sehr nice.
Genau, so ganz
klein hab ich, ich glaub, die hat noch mal einen.
Damit kann man,
schauen wir mal, wie das ausschaut.
Damit kannst du quasi
Pins analysieren, also sprich,
du kannst dann den
Logic Analyzer anschließen an so
einen Kabel, beispielsweise sind vier
Pins, dieses GPIO,
anschließen und dann kannst du quasi mitschneiden und siehst,
was die wie übertragen.
Und wenn du dann eine Spezifikation
von den Protokollern hast, guckst du dir, was die übertragen,
dann kannst du das probieren, im ESP32
nachzubauen. Wenn er es
im Hardware-Rate laufen lässt, funktioniert auch die
LED-Error-Anzeige. Ja, aber nur, weil er
einen Rate-Controller hat, der das kann.
Wie gesagt, ich hab ja hier mein
Onboard, ähm,
was ist denn da drauf?
Ja, also
das Board,
da ist irgendein
Mainboard,
Adapt-Tag, irgendein, ähm,
ah, der Link
geht gar nicht mehr, exzellent.
Ähm,
also sprich,
weiß nicht, ob man hier irgendwie den Name
vom Mainboard sieht, da kann ich dir sagen, was ich da
für ein, ja, hier,
irgendwo hier steht
der,
what the fuck,
das hier ist das Mainboard, was da drin ist,
das ist das Mainboard, was da drin ist,
und der hat
Rate,
oder Sass,
der hat einen LSI
3008, was auch immer drauf, und dieser Controller,
da ist er übrigens hier unten drunter,
und dieser Controller kann kein, ähm,
also hier ist der Mini, dieser Mini-Sass-Connector für die, für die Festplatten,
und normalerweise gibt es die Möglichkeit, dass man dort so einen Side-Kabel mit rausführt,
neben der Festplatten-Connector, und anschließt an die Festplatten-Backplane,
und dieser Controller, der hier auf dem Board ist, der kann das nicht, der unterstützt das Ansteuern von LEDs nicht.
Also, shit, shit, Herr, das kannst du, ne, kannst du nix machen.
Und deswegen hatte ich damals vor, mal das selbst nachzubauen, mit einem ESP32,
und,
ich hab's dann nie gemacht, ja, ich mach's jetzt hier über die Onboard, mit den, über die,
hier, ich hab hier Onboard, äh,
SGPIO, sieht man ja hier unten,
Anschlüsse, darüber hab ich das jetzt gemacht,
das ist zwar für den Onboard-Intel-Controller, was aber egal ist, weil man kann das über den
Skript aus Linux raus, von manuell setzen.
Generell muss man sagen, der Aufwand ist eigentlich viel zu groß,
und die Hardware, die das in Kombination kann, ist in der Regel auch viel zu teuer,
die einfachere Variante ist tatsächlich, Festplatte dran, und
von nem Software-RAID zu nem ZFS-RAID 1, zu vielleicht sogar ganz ohne RAID, zumal eher synchen,
und einfach nen Aufkleber vorne drauf.
Welche Seriennummer das Ding hat, und fertig.
Natürlich ist es schöner mit ner LED, keine Frage, aber den Aufwand rechtfertigt sich's eigentlich, eigentlich gar nicht, weil,
aber den Aufwand rechtfertigt sich's eigentlich, eigentlich gar nicht, weil,
man da nicht die passende Hardware eh schon für hat.
So, gucken wir mal weiter. Achso, ich wollte ja mal kurz schauen, was hat er denn.
Wie gesagt, 4E-Kiste, gleiche Gehäuse, was ich auch hab, was da drin ist, muss man mal gucken.
Das sieht mir alles irgendwie nach HP aus, oder Dell?
Dell, HP?
Eher Dell?
Untere HP, obere Dell?
Und beides Dell?
Schwer zu sagen, was ist das? Dell!
Hier steht's. Das ist ne Dell-Kiste.
Witzigerweise haben die ganzen, also, Dell, HP, IBM.
Oder Lenovo.
Die haben alle so ne gewisse Optik, woran man sie erkennt.
Also, man muss ja witzigerweise sagen, dass die ein einheitliches Hardware-Branding, oder was auch immer haben,
für Server-Hardware als sonst.
Also, gerade die alten IBM-Kisten fand ich ja persönlich ganz cool,
die vorne noch diesen,
die vorne noch diese Metallkugel drin hatten.
Wann ist das noch so, Welt?
Es gab mal olle IBM-Dinger, die hatten, neben dem Logo hier,
hatten die immer hier so ne kleine Metallkugel drinne.
Das sind schon die ganz alten, wo ich mich immer gefragt hab, was macht diese Metallkugel da drin?
Hab ich nie gecheckt.
Das war einfach nur, dass man erkennt, das ist IBM anscheinend, ja.
Olle fette Playcenter?
Ne.
Ne, hier auf der linken Seite war das, glaub ich.
Ist, ist ja auch egal jetzt.
Interessiert das überhaupt, ob da irgendwie ein bisschen Metall vorne dran ist, oder nicht.
Äh, Twinkor, ja.
Genau das, auf dem Stand bin ich mittlerweile auch.
Scheiß drauf, auf diese komischen, äh, Magic-Geschichten,
über diese Propri-, ne, sind ja nicht Propri-,
diese Nischenprotokolle da zu übertragen.
Die beste Variante ist wirklich, hau irgendwie nen ZFS drauf,
oder meinetwegen auch n Software, irgendwas,
Seriennummern aufschreiben und fertig.
Ich mein, die Zuordnung musst du ja immer noch machen.
Oder aber, ähm, was man bei ZFS machen könnte, ist, ähm,
man könnte, man könnte die, die weiße so nennen wie die Seriennummer.
Aber man muss die Seriennummer trotzdem irgendwie drauf, äh, draufschreiben, ja.
Also man irgendwie, irgendwie musst du ja nach wie vor die Zuordnung machen zwischen,
äh, was meint das ZFS-Rate, was kaputt ist und was, in welchem Slot steckt das Ganze drin.
Und ich find, grad für den Heimbereich ist es am einfachsten, einfach Seriennummer drauf und gut ist.
So.
Was ist das hier unten für ne Kiste?
Kann ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht zuordnen.
Steht auch kein Hersteller drauf.
Irgendein Storage-Ding.
Irgendein fettes Storage-Ding auf jeden Fall.
Das ist etwas, was viel zu viel Strom verbraucht für meinen Geschmack,
um es sich daheim hinzustellen.
Aber bei den Amis ist Strom, net up, ah, net up, okay.
Aber, und da unten dürfte ne USV sein.
Aber bei den Amis ist Strom ja eh generell, glaub, billiger.
Wofür braucht man sowas für zu Hause?
Naja, brauchen, brauchen ist relativ, ja.
Ich glaube, ich glaube ehrlich gesagt, es geht eher ums Haben.
Also die wenigsten Leute werden hier so viel Speicherplatz brauchen,
wobei, der hat es ja auch nur halb,
der hat es ja auch nur ein Viertel befüllt.
Bissl Speicherplatz.
Viele Leute haben nen Plex-Server daheim laufen.
Aber den Sinn von nem Plex-Server hat sich mir bisher nie erschlossen.
Es sei denn, man hat nen riesen Vorrat gebunkert
an selbstverständlich legal erworbenen Serien und Filmen.
Und man möchte die Filme doppelt und dreifach angucken.
Dann ist ein Plex-Server irgendwie sinnvoll.
Aber ansonsten versteh ich den Sinn von nem Plex-Server nicht.
Weil ganz, ganz im Ernst.
Ich guck mir nen Film einmal, vielleicht zweimal an,
vielleicht zweimal, vielleicht ein bisschen im Abstand,
wenn er, wenn er mir wirklich gut gefallen hat.
Und das stream ich über Amazon oder Netflix oder irgendwas.
Ich will den gar nicht bei mir lokal auf irgendeiner Festplatte liegen haben.
Wozu?
Da liegen alle Dokumente und Fotos drauf.
Ja, wenn die 16, 16, 16 Terabyte wirklich brauchen.
Also ich hatte in der alten Kiste, hatte ich 3 mal 10 Terabyte ZFS-Rate.
Raid, äh, ZFS-Rate.
Was war denn das?
Das Raid 5 Gegenstück von ZFS.
War das ZFS-Rate 1?
Also das, was wie Raid 5 ist.
Eine Festplatte kann kaputt gehen.
Halt dich da drauf laufen.
Ich glaub 1, ne?
Ich glaub 1 ist es.
ZFS 1.
Halt dich drauf.
Das waren dann im Endeffekt unterm Strich 20 Terabyte.
War ne richtig coole Geschichte.
War halt ne fette, fette Kiste.
48 Gigabyte RAM.
16 Kerne.
Oder 8 Kerne?
16?
8 Kerne.
Für die Zeit ordentlich 2 mal 10 Gigabit Anbindung und so.
Performance war wirklich top.
Ja, noch mit SSDs drinne.
Aber ich bin dann irgendwann zu dem Schluss gekommen.
Ey, einfach totaler Overkill für daheim.
Nichtsdestotrotz war das relativ, wenn die Festplatten im Idle waren, relativ stromsparend das Ding.
Also da kann man Intel ja nix vorwerfen.
Also gar nicht Server-Hardware.
Das komplette Rack hat unter 100 Watt Idle gebraucht.
Inklusive dem ganzen Switch und geduldens was da drin ist.
Switch, Fritzbox, ähm, unten die USV.
Der ganze Shit hat unter 100 Watt Idle gebraucht.
Was eigentlich ziemlich wenig ist.
Trotzdem unnütz Oversized für das, was ich daheim machen will.
Bin ich da nach 2-3 Jahren drauf gekommen, dass das eigentlich total Oversized ist.
So, okay.
Also er hat irgendeine Storage-Lösung.
Dell-Kiste.
Bisschen ältere Dell-Kiste wahrscheinlich.
Und ne USV.
Alles klar.
Gucken wir mal weiter.
Der oben kann...
Ich seh die Seriennummer.
Bei IBM gibt's ne Sache.
Ähm...
Bei IBM nennt sich das nicht Seriennummer, sondern FRU.
IBM FRU.
Ich weiß gar nicht wofür.
Field Replacement Unit.
Okay.
Und da sind die einzelnen Teile aus diesem Server.
Also sprich, wenn man nen Netzteil nachbestellen will bei IBM, dann musste man die FRU-Nummer wissen.
Und die FRU-Nummer steht halt immer irgendwo innen drauf.
Und wir hatten damals immer riesen Diskussionen mit IBM, dass wir jetzt...
Der Server ist nicht kaputt.
Wir wollen ihn jetzt auch nicht ausschalten.
Aber IBM hat gesagt, wir können euch nur was schicken, wenn ihr uns die richtige FRU-Nummer
sagt.
Und da haben wir gesagt, wir können euch genau...
Wir können euch die FRU-Nummer vom Server sagen.
Dann müsst ihr doch wissen, was da für ne Hardware...
Für nen Netzteil drin ist.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Wir brauchen die FRU-Nummer.
Sonst können wir nichts machen.
Also FRU-Nummer hat sich bei mir eingebrannt bei IBM.
Ähm...
Allerdings muss man sagen, ich hab damals die Schuldkompetenz...
Ich hab damals die Schuld komplett IBM gegeben.
Allerdings im Nachhinein überlegt, muss man sagen, die Schuld damals lag mit...
Lag auch mit bei uns.
Weil ähm...
Da gab's...
Ja, mittlerweile ist es ja Lenovo.
Mittlerweile ist es ja nicht bei IBM.
Ähm...
Da...
Die haben ganz...
Ja, ja, kannst du online...
Kannst du online machen.
Zumindest...
Die Schuld lag damals auch zum Teil bei uns.
Weil wir hätten einfach...
Das ist mir jetzt Jahre später aufgefallen.
Wir hätten einfach...
Wir waren ja...
Wir haben ja zum größten Teil die gleichen Server.
Man hätte einfach einmalig, wenn man einen neuen Server-Typ einbaut, ähm...
sich notieren müssen, die kompletten FRU-Nummern von allen Hardware-Teilen.
Dann hätte man nämlich die FRU-Nummer denen sagen können.
Haben wir nicht gemacht.
Wir haben jedes Mal neu den Server aufgemacht, FRU-Nummer abgeschrieben.
Da bin ich Jahre später erst drauf gekommen, dass das nicht IBMs Schuld alleine war, sondern
unser, äh...
Infrastruktur-Management-Geschichten da irgendwie ziemlich versagt haben.
Ja.
Und dafür braucht man ein paar Jahre, bis man das...
Bis man das kapiert.
Ja.
Okay.
Jetzt kommt Netzwerk.
Okay, okay.
Also was haben wir da?
Das ist ein UniFi.
Ne, das ist irgendwie...
Das erkenne ich nicht.
Kann man die Auflösung höher machen?
Was ist das?
Okay, das erkenne ich nicht.
Also was haben wir denn hier?
Irgendein Cisco-Switch.
Warum auch immer Cisco sein muss, wenn man zu viel Geld hat, kann man sich Cisco-Kisten
kaufen.
Meistens...
Die meisten Leute kaufen sich ja keine Cisco-Kisten.
Sondern kaufen sich gebrauchte Cisco-Kisten, weil Cisco-Kisten neu und modern zu teuer
sind.
Ähm...
Und dann hast du irgendeinen Uralt-Switch, der zwar günstig ist, aber extrem laut, Uralt
und auch nicht mal auf dem Stand der Technik.
Also ich persönlich bin ja Mikrotik-Fanboy, was Heimnetzwerk-Geschichten angeht und UniFi-Zeug,
was Access-Points angeht.
Die...
Ubiquiti 10G-Switch, der ist auch ziemlich gut.
Aber ein Cisco-Ding daheim hinstelle, weiß ich nicht.
Zumal man auch sagen muss, dass die Konfiguration über das Webinterface von so einem Mikrotik,
wenn es auch ein bisschen kompliziert ist, gerade was WLANs angeht, ähm...
Unnötig kompliziert ist es bei Mikrotik, ja.
Aber ähm...
Die...
Die Cisco...
Cisco CLI ist...
Wenn man es oft macht, ist Cisco CLI...
Ähm...
Eingängig, ja.
Also man muss...
Man muss echt sagen, dass Cisco sich da viel Gedanken macht.
Also sprich über...
Cisco Switch über eine Konsole einrichten, wenn man das öfters macht, ist wirklich gut.
Aber...
Das ist so eine Sache, wenn man das einmal macht und dann drei Jahre nicht machen muss
und dann geht irgendwas nicht und dann musst du es wieder machen, dann fängst du wieder
von vorne an.
Deswegen mag ich das Mikrotik Webinterface.
Im Prinzip ist Mikrotik ja auch nichts anderes wie ein Linux mit Webinterface.
Unten drunter ist da auch ein IP-Table und sonst was, nur dass es halt die passende Hardware
drunter ist, ne.
Also da ist kein x86 sonst was drin, sondern irgendwas optimierteres für Netzwerkgeschichten.
Also gerade im Heimbereich finde ich Mikrotik eine super Geschichte.
Die SG-Serie ehemals...
Linksus.
Stimmt.
Das war die Linksus.
Früher war das Linksus powered by Cisco.
Mittlerweile haben sie ja Linksus weggeschmissen.
Ja.
Und das ist wahrscheinlich sein Kabelmodem.
Geh ich mal von aus.
Ja.
habe ich bis jetzt auch noch keinen Anwendungszweck für gehabt. Ich habe meine
meine Shelly Relays, die Smart Light machen.
Ok, also Kabelmodem wahrscheinlich, irgendein Patchpanel, tja,
noch irgendein extra Switch, keine Ahnung, vielleicht PoE, vielleicht für PoE,
weiß nicht. Irgendein Switch und tja, was ist das hier unten?
Den Anschluss und nachzufolge ein Receiver für Fernseh, Fernsehempfang?
Vielleicht? Erkennt man, weiß ich nicht.
Einfach, das ist so eine typische Ami-Geschichte, einfach ein Brett an die
Wand und die Sachen dran gehängt.
Eigentlich finde ich ganz cool, warum nicht? Warum nicht, ja? Übrigens bei mir,
bei mir, bei mir, bei mir, bei mir, bei mir, bei mir, bei mir,
bei mir im Keller würde ich das nicht machen. Wir haben eine saumäßig hohe
Luftfeuchtigkeit. Ich weiß nicht, wie gut, dass die Dinger verkraften auf Dauer.
Aber ich wollte mir schon eine ganze Weile einen Netzwerkschrank kaufen, so einen
kleinen und bei mir in den Serverraum machen, weil der Serverraum ist übelst
hoch, also die Decke ist ziemlich hoch. Ich habe da nach oben massig Platz, der
ungenutzt ist.
Max und Cisco, nee, das kann nicht sein. Nee, kann auch nicht sein.
Aber alles in einem dedizierten Ort ist sicherlich hilfreich. Und es hilft,
einige der Dinger auch zu organisieren. Die Kraft auf dem Dach ist in der
größten Fläche des Servers.
Ja. Nee, 48 HE-Rack, nee, das will ich nicht. Das Problem am 48 HE-Rack ist, ich habe ja so
einen Mini-Rack hier hinten stehen. Der Serverraum ist zu kurz dafür. Also man
sieht es ja hier, wenn ich, hier stehe ich in der Tür, guck mal, also sprich, das
sieht jetzt vielleicht größer aus, als es ist, aber hier schräg ist die Tür. Also
das Rack kann nicht größer sein. Das ist, glaube ich, nur 40 Zentimeter tief. Das ist
so ein Mini, wirklich so ein Mini. Das ist ein bisschen größer als ein Netzwerkschrank,
was ich hier habe. Aber es ist, ich glaube, nur 40 Zentimeter tief. Das ist, ich glaube,
es ist nur 40 oder 35, 40 Zentimeter tief. Mehr passt da nicht rein. Und der
Server, den ich hier oben habe, der passt da auch nur rein, weil es ein ganz
kurzes Gehäuse ist. So, und ich wollte hier oben, was man jetzt nicht so genau
sieht, also hier gegenüber, oben an der Wand, wollte ich noch einen Netzwerkschrank
hinmachen, weil hier hinten ist der, hier, warte mal, hier hinten sieht man was, hier
hinten geht der Kabelkanal rein mit dem ganzen Scheiß aus dem Keller, aus dem
Erdgeschoss und hier zu meinem Schreibtisch neben. Und da oben könnte man
schon einen Netzwerkschrank hinmachen. Da kann ich eben auch den Kram hier teilweise
raus machen.
Hab mehr Platz. Wobei aktuell der Server eh nicht mehr an ist. Egal, wir gucken
jetzt erstmal sein Setup-Video hier weiter. Wie wäre es, die Tür einfach zu
versetzen? Gar nicht. Wie willst du, wie willst du die, wie willst du da, wie willst
du da die Tür versetzen? Hier ist der Türrahmen und hier ist der Raum. Wie willst
du da die Tür versetzen? Äh, 12, 15? Ich glaube, 15 HE ist es, glaube ich. 12 oder
15? 5, 15 ist es, glaube ich. Ja. 1, 2, 3...
Warte mal, ne, Moment. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 12? 13? 13, 14? Ich würde,
ich bleib mal trotzdem bei, bei 15, weil unten drunter kommt noch was unter der,
hier ist noch eins frei unter der, 12 oder 15? Das ist nicht so groß. Weiter.
Das ist das Ziel. Es ist irgendwie aus dem Weg und alle Körbe sind
abgehängt. Was hat er denn da oben hängen? Ist das ein Raspberry Pi Zero? Sieht aus
wie ein Raspberry Pi Zero. Gibt es ein günstiges Modem als Ersatz für die Vodafone OM Trashbox?
Äh, Modem, ja. Wenn du, wenn du ein Kabelmodem haben willst, es gibt einzelne Kabelmodems,
aber so die, so die Kombination, wenn du, wenn du noch mehr als das Modem da dran verwendest,
äh, dann bleibt dir eigentlich aus deiner Fritzbox nichts anderes übrig. Eine Kabelmodem,
ne? Eine Kabelmodem, ne? Eine Kabelmodem, ne? Eine Kabelmodem, ne? Eine Kabelmodem, ne? Eine Kabelmodem,
Ne? Eine Kabelmodem, ne? Eine Kabelmodem, ne? Eine Kabelmodem, ne? Kabelmodem, eine Kabel,
also, sprich wenn du das WLAN drin verwendest und irgendwie anderes Zeug, Telefonie und
sowas dann, ähm, geht eigentlich nur ne Fritzbox als Kombi.
Also, so ich hab das Unity Media Ding und dahinter nen MikroTik-Router, der alles macht
und das Unity Media Ding macht halt nur mehr oder weniger Kabelmodem. Genau, zum Beispiel
hier das was der Dwinkel gerade geschrieben hat. Es gibt noch ein paar und da gibt, es
gibt, irgendwie ein Try Tech Ding Modem und so, aber ganz ehrlich, wenn man sogar, naja,
regionale.
Wenn man alles, wenn man mehr als das Modem braucht, würde ich mir eine Fritzbox kaufen.
Also wenn man das WLAN verwendet von der Unity Media Box und sonstiges.
Eine Fritzbox mag jetzt nicht in den einzelnen Bereichen so toll sein.
Also eine Fritzbox ist von den Funktionen her kein guter Router, kein guter Switch, kein gutes NAS, kein gutes...
Aber die Kombination ist halt das, was so eine Fritzbox nach wie vor immer noch ziemlich brauchbar macht.
Und gerade die Kombination aus VoIP, ZIP und DECT, was du mit der Fritzbox machen kannst, ist wunderbar.
Weil das ist was, das willst du wirklich nicht selber machen.
Also wie man eine DECT Basisstation macht, hätte ich eh schon mal gar keinen Plan.
Und gerade ZIP und VoIP gedöhnt selbst machen ist komplett für den Arsch.
Wie ein Druide in WoW ist die Fritzbox, genau.
Oh, Fiber, Fiber.
Ah, ich habe ja vergessen, wir sind nicht in Deutschland.
Die haben sowas wie Fiber.
Und der hat auch 300 hoch, 300 runter.
Ich habe, fragt mich nicht, was habe ich denn?
400 runter und 100...
Ne, ich habe keine Ahnung, ich weiß es gar nicht.
Ich glaube 400, 400 runter und 40 ab.
Kann das sein?
Keine Ahnung.
Also wenn man Kabel machen kann, ist Kabel best.
Klar, aber an Stellen, wo man...
Wenn man eben kein Kabel machen kann, weil kein Kabel da ist,
dann ist Wireless halt auch nicht ohne.
Weil was anderes wirst du nicht machen können.
Wie gesagt, gerade meine Außenkamera am Hof,
da geht halt kein PoE.
Weil da ist halt nix.
Kein Kabel und sonst was in der Nähe.
Ich meine, ja, ich könnte einen PoE Injektor kaufen,
den am Strom anschließen
und dahinter dann einen WLAN Access Point Bridge machen.
Aber dann hast du quasi drei Geräte,
anstatt eine Kamera über Wireless.
Und es ist immer noch Wireless, ja.
Nur die Kamera denkt nicht, dass es Wireless ist.
Stimmt.
Und bei Ami-Häusern ist kein Problem.
Da kannst du ja einfach durch die Zwischenwand den ganzen Kram ziehen
und Löcher reinbohren und rausschneiden und so.
Ja, das stimmt.
Bei Ami-Häusern ist es kein Problem.
Freedom House.
Putting holes in walls.
Das können auch nur die Amis sagen.
Ich habe die Kamera außen montiert letztens hier.
Wie gesagt, ich habe mir das Ding gekauft,
was jetzt an der Woche den Geist aufgegeben hat.
Habe ich außen montiert an der Wand.
Und ich war low-brain.
Also bohren und sowas, da habe ich noch nicht so viel Erfahrung,
was diese Heimwerker-Sachen angeht.
Zumindest habe ich meinen 12-Volt-Akku,
Akkuschrauber geholt, Bohrer reingemacht,
zweiten Gang eingeschaltet.
Ähm.
Und dann wollte ich das Ding quasi vor das Fenster in der Küche machen.
Und da habe ich das angesetzt, in die Wand reingebohrt.
Und das geht zwei Zentimeter,
ne, zwei Zentimeter nicht,
geht einen Zentimeter in die Wand rein
und dann ist Stopp.
Dann geht es einfach nicht weiter.
Dann geht es, dann geht es einfach nicht weiter.
Ähm.
Und irgendwann bin ich dann,
bin ich dann drauf, drauf, drauf gekommen,
dass
an der Stelle wohl irgendwelche Metall,
weiß nicht, Träger werden es nicht sein,
Metallstücke in der Wand sind.
Darauf bin ich aber erst gekommen,
nachdem ich da zwei Minuten volle Pulle dagegen gedrückt habe.
Und ich gedacht habe, Alter, das muss doch weitergehen.
Und ich habe mich schon gewundert,
warum, ähm,
warum es so einfach den ersten Zentimeter reinging in die Wand
und danach gar nicht.
So.
Und dann,
Alter, geht nicht, geht nicht, geht nicht, geht nicht,
habe ich dagegen gedrückt, dagegen gedrückt, dagegen gedrückt.
Kannst du vergessen.
Ging nicht.
Und dann habe ich das rausgezogen und den Fehler gemacht,
beim Ablegen den Bohrer anzugreifen.
Könnt ihr euch vorstellen, wer sich den Finger verbrannt hat.
So.
Genau.
So, und dann bin ich einfach zwei Zentimeter weiter gegangen
und dann ging es easy in die Wand rein.
Komplett.
Drei Zentimeter für den Dübel.
Gar kein Problem.
Da ist irgendein Metallträger.
Hier, weil der Chat gerade so lacht über 12 Volt Akkuschrauber.
Wenn man ab und zu mal,
wenn man ab und zu mal ein Loch in die Wand bohren will,
ist das überhaupt kein Problem hier.
Moment, das ist der mit Schlagen.
Den habe ich nicht.
Ich habe den da.
Das ist damit überhaupt gar kein Problem.
Ja, das ist das Set,
was ich mir mal vor ein paar Jahren gekauft habe.
Überhaupt kein Ding.
Sind sogar Bohrers dabei.
Das da ist für.
Hallo.
Das da ist für Holz und das da ist für, frag mir nicht, Steine oder so.
Und das ist überhaupt kein Problem, da Löcher in die Wand zu bohren.
Wirklich überhaupt kein Ding.
Es gibt auch Tests auf YouTube, da bohren die mit dem Ding durch richtig hartes Zeug durch.
Es ist wirklich überhaupt kein Problem.
Außer man hat halt Metall in der Wand.
So.
und ich hatte an der stelle metall in der wand ich habe eigentlich auch so ein detektor den
habe ich aber nicht mit rausgenommen und wie gesagt zwei zentimeter weiter überhaupt kein
ding geht wie butter rein dübel zack gut doch guck mal weiter ja okay das muss man sich so
im detail anguckt mich so das hat er okay es ist wirklich links ist aber es ist doch so oder
es ist das ehemalige links das zeug oder nicht das ist das ehemalige links des zeugs ja wie
gesagt ich würde mir eine mikrotik switch hin machen da gibt es auch schon gleich welche mit
10g dabei und zweimal 10g und 26 ports und sowas
okay das ist jetzt relativ langweilig was hat er sonst noch aus dass das bestimmt für
p o e das bestimmt für p o e tainzer verschenkt wieder drei abos dankeschön exzellent und dreimal
und zwar wer hat denn das glück was zu kriegen dankeschön für die gegnerin
giften saps knall hibia kriegt was don vito og und wald ach an kriegt was okay ist router
os gut ja ziemlich gut manche sachen wie wlan es ein bisschen unnötig kompliziert zu konfigurieren
aber von den möglichkeiten der ist router os wirklich top router os kannst du konfigurieren
je nachdem wie es dir wie es dir lieber ist über ein web interface über einen über eine
software für windows die übrigens auch in den linux läuft
mit mit wine aber ziemlich gut und über komando zeile
das bestimmt für p o e
ist er ich wusste ich wusste dass wenn man so was jetzt muss p o e sein weil das
sonst gehabt keinen sinn dass er das noch mal extra drin hat
what the hell was ist das
the cable
i haven't had cable for a while
probably ten fans gegen fuel fans
das nächste
ab okay es ist wirklich so philips uζ cases 86 zwei monate dankeschön
last but not least
was bei эnych trial 0
es hat ume mach instrumenten
es hat einen tree als ver flick 0
merkel
mesk
player
da
Und was macht der?
Ja und wofür ist der?
Also wenn ich in Raspberry Pi brauche, dass mein Home-Network weiter funktioniert, dann ist irgendwas verkehrt.
Ach so.
Okay.
Ja, aber okay.
Warum gehen die Server überhaupt in Deep Sleep?
Also ich meine, okay, Moment.
Warum, warum, warum?
Was?
Okay, Moment, das erschließt sich mir jetzt nicht.
Da hat ein Raspberry Pi, der pingt seine Home-Server.
Wenn der Home-Server, also wenn der Server nicht mehr da ist, schickt er ihm ein Wake-on-Lan-Signal.
Also sprich, der möchte, dass sein Server die ganze Zeit läuft.
Warum, warum schaltet er den Standby bei den Servern nicht einfach aus?
Stromausfall.
Ja, aber wenn man einen Stromausfall hat, wenn man einen Stromausfall hat, dann geht doch danach auch kein Wake-on-Lan mehr.
Oh.
Oder?
Kann man einen Rechner, der komplett aus war, Wake-on-Lan starten?
Das kommt wahrscheinlich darauf an, was der nach dem Power-on wieder macht.
Ich dachte eigentlich, Wake-on-Lan geht nur, wenn ich den Rechner quasi runterfahre, sodass der halt Netzwerkkarte und Gedulds anlässt.
Genau, das ist eine Hardware, okay, das kann natürlich sein, das ist eine Hardware-Geschichte.
Also sprich, wenn der Rechner quasi komplett aus war und wieder angeht, also das Netzwerk wieder,
das hängt aber wahrscheinlich auch davon ab, was das Mainboard macht, ne?
Genau, wollte ich gerade sagen, das hängt ja auch davon ab, was das Mainboard macht.
Also sprich, das Mainboard muss danach wieder angehen und im besten Fall nicht...
Aber dann könnte der Rechner doch auch so einstellen, dass der einfach wieder komplett bootet nach Power-Loss.
Also sprich, der muss doch kein Wake-on-Lan machen, der kann doch einfach den Rechner so einstellen, dass der wieder hochfährt, nachdem es ausgeht.
Ja gut, was auch immer.
Er wird seinen Grund dafür haben, so genau erschließen tut sich es mir aber auf jeden Fall nicht.
Wo ich das gerade sehe, mir fehlt übrigens immer noch, ich habe ja immer noch keine Monitoring-Geschichte für meine Heimgedulds gefunden, die mir gefällt.
Also das, was ich jetzt laufen habe, ist im Prinzip so ein behelfsmäßiges Problem.
Prometheus Grafana, was ein paar Sachen pinkt, ja, das war's.
Zabbix ist mir zu overkill und zu beknackt zu konfigurieren.
Nagios, auch wenn ich ja einen gewissen Schwach... wie sagt man da?
Schwäche habe für Nagios, ja, ich mag Nagios, ist mir Nagios ein bisschen zu oldschool für daheim.
Irgendwie habe ich noch kein schönes, simples, easy-as-fuck-Monitoring gefunden, was einfach nur geht für daheim.
Wahrscheinlich bleibe ich bei meinem...
Prometheus-Kram, was einfach nur pinkt, nur ein bisschen Grafana-Dashboard.
PRTG, nee, PRTG fällt schon raus, weil es Windows-only ist.
CheckMK finde ich auch nicht so schön.
CheckMK ist ja quasi eine Nagios mit ein bisschen Oberfläche.
Irgendwas richtig, sowas Schönes, sinnvolles.
Kennt ihr diese Pinger-Seiten?
Es gibt ein paar Seiten, die einfach nichts anderes als Ping machen, mit einer schönen Oberfläche zum Einrichten.
Oder es gibt so ein paar Cloud-Monitoring-Geschichten.
Geschichten, die auch einen Free-Plan haben, die können dann quasi drei, vier Sachen.
Die können pingen, die können TCP-Verbindungen machen, HTTP und einen Regex filtern und sowas.
Sowas für daheim, das würde mir voll und ganz reichen.
Was für smarte Geräte hast du zu Hause?
Boah, viel.
Von Relays bis zu 3D-Druckern, bis jede Menge ESPs und Gedöns, ein paar Raspberries.
Ich habe irgendwo ein Textdokument.
Ja, Steckerleiste, Steckerleiste, geflashten Staubsauger, total viel, total viel Gedöns.
Sowas wie Uptime-Robot im Endeffekt, sowas in die Richtung.
Ja, Statping allein, nee, Cached ist ja quasi eher so ein Ausfall-Block, also so ein Ausfall-Verfügbarkeitsbericht-Generator.
Ja, ein bisschen sowas wie Statping.
Weiß nicht, ob Statping...
Ich habe mir das alles schon mal angeguckt und es hat mir alles nicht gefallen.
Ich glaube, da war Statping auch dabei.
Was druckst du denn so?
Zum Beispiel Gehäuse für mein TTGO-T-Displayboard hier, was wir gestern programmiert haben im Stream.
So, gucken wir mal weiter.
Super.
Okay, der macht das wirklich, der macht das wirklich wegen, wegen, äh, wegen Power-Stromausfall.
Hast du schon einen Piehole?
Nicht mehr, hatte ich eine Weile, aber, ähm, hat sich nicht, als nicht so sinnvoll für mich rausgestellt.
Weil YouTube und Twitch-Werbung kannst du damit nicht mehr blocken, seitdem die das Big Brain gemacht haben und Content und Werbung von den gleichen Servern ausliefern.
Also du kannst keine...
Du kannst keine Chance.
Äh, und das wäre Twitch und YouTube blocken, ist das, was ich eigentlich brauche.
Ähm, YouTube geht doch.
Also, vielleicht geht das mittlerweile wieder, weil die irgendwie was gefunden haben.
Zumindest Twitch geht definitiv nicht.
Und, äh, YouTube ging auch eine ganze Weile nicht.
Vielleicht haben sie es mittlerweile, vielleicht haben sie mittlerweile was rausgefunden, wie es bei YouTube doch wieder geht.
Aber, wo ich mir das zum letzten Mal anguckt habe, ging es bei YouTube und Twitch nicht.
Und bei Twitch bin ich mir ziemlich sicher, geht es immer noch nicht.
Und gerade für Mobile wäre das halt wichtig.
Und, äh, U-Block Origin bringt dir aber auf einem iPhone nichts.
Gerade für Twitch und YouTube auf dem iPhone wäre das ultra praktisch gewesen, dass es die Werbung blocken kann.
So.
Ähm, dafür wäre das richtig gut gewesen.
Auf dem Desktop ist das kein Problem.
Auf dem Desktop habe ich ja einen Adblocker, sowas wie U-Block Origin.
Deswegen ist das da für mich eigentlich relativ überflüssig, nachdem es Mobile nicht das blocken kann, was ich möchte, dass es blockt.
Und auf dem Desktop, ich eh quasi einen besseren Adblocker habe, brauche ich es nicht.
YouTube fürs Handy only, wenn es ja, aber nicht auf dem iPhone.
Man könnte, tatsächlich, man könnte einen Browser verwenden mit Adblocker und YouTube im Browser verwenden.
Allerdings, gerade auf dem iPhone ist es im Browser deutlich hakeliger als mit der, mit der YouTube App.
Ähm, also man kann, man kann auf dem iPhone auch, äh, YouTube über den Browser verwenden.
Es gibt sogar ein paar Browser, die machen das möglich, dass man im Hintergrund YouTube Videos abspielen kann.
Ja, auch wenn Apple das nicht will, aber ein paar Browser können das.
Und, ähm, aber die Bedienung mit der YouTube App ist halt deutlich einfacher.
Und es geht halt ums iPhone, ja.
Auf meinem, auf meinen Android Tablets ist kein Problem.
Dann habe ich, da habe ich einen Adblock YouTube, äh, Vanced ist ja quasi die, YouTube Vanced ist ja quasi die YouTube App mit einem Adblocker drin.
U-Pipe gibt es auch noch, genau.
Auf dem, auf den Android Tablets ist es überhaupt kein Problem.
Aber auf dem iPhone halt.
Oder auf den beiden iPhones.
Das ist halt, auf den, nein, auf den drei, äh, mittlerweile sind es ja fucking drei iPhones schon.
Ich glaube es nicht.
Warum eigentlich?
Naja.
Massig, also ob, wenn ich mir überlege, wie viel Scheiß ich mir da eigentlich schon mittlerweile am Start habe.
Ich glaube, es sind mittlerweile, es sind immer beide, irgendwie bei elf Android Tablets.
Insgesamt, davon sind nicht, natürlich nicht alle im, im Betrieb, ja.
Kein Mensch braucht elf Tablets.
Und drei iPhones.
Das setzt sich zusammen aus einem iPhone SE von meiner Mutter.
Aus einem iPhone SE.
Aus einem iPhone 6S von mir.
Und aus einem iPhone L, äh, X, XS oder so von mir.
Allerdings, äh, die zwei iPhones davon, die habe ich mir nicht selbst gekauft.
Die würde ich mir wahrscheinlich auch nicht selbst kaufen.
Das einzige iPhone, was ich gekauft habe, ist für meine Mutter das iPhone SE.
Ähm, und die anderen beiden sind da, wo ich, sind von da, wo ich arbeite.
Die kriegt man da zur Verfügung gestellt.
Sonst hätte ich mir wahrscheinlich auch was anderes gekauft.
Ja, es gibt aber Basti EW.
Es gibt ein paar trickreiche Custom-Browser-Anbieter.
Das ist zwar der WebView unten drunter immer noch Safari.
Aber die haben es geschafft, dass es im Hintergrund läuft.
YouTube-Videos und so.
Also, der Oper-, der alte Opera Mini konnte das zum Beispiel.
Und den anderen weiß ich grad nicht, wie der heißt.
Da müsste ich jetzt auf mein iPhone irgendwo gucken, weil ich drüben im Schlafzimmer liegen hab.
Der hatte zumindest einen total bescheuerten Namen, aber der kann auch im Hintergrund abspielen.
Ähm, ich trenne Privat- und Firmenhandys immer.
Ja, sollte ich vielleicht auch machen, aber habe ich nicht.
Ich will keine Zwei-Handys-Benutzung mitnehmen. Wozu?
Außerdem bräuchte ich da einen Mobilfunkvertrag, einen eigenen noch.
Wozu?
Ja, hätte Aldi Talk die Möglichkeit, eine zweite SIM-Karte zu bekommen, dann wäre das okay.
Weil dann könnten, könnten wir uns einen Vertrag teilen.
Weil ich würde Datenflatrate,
also ich würde, ich würde die Datensachen verbrauchen und nicht telefonieren, weil ich so gut wie nie telefoniere.
Meine Mutter wird die, äh, Telefonie-Sachen aufbrauchen.
Aber Aldi Talk macht keine zwei SIMs.
Zwei Profile auf dem iPhone.
Ja, könnte man machen, aber wozu?
Wozu?
Ja, viel ist da nicht dran.
So, ich, ich, der muss auch mal seinen Server zeigen.
Ja, da, da bin ich jetzt gespannt drauf.
Also was?
Genau, der Browser, richtig, Privat heißt der, korrekt.
Privat und dann noch irgendwas hinten dran.
Der hat nen übelst, äh, fishy Namen, aber der funktioniert ganz gut.
Ich will's gar nicht so sehr an die große Glocke hängen, weil vielleicht macht Apple den sonst raus.
So, also was hat er denn? 18 Höheneinheiten Rack.
Open Frame, ja, so wie bei mir.
Nur, das ist von der Tiefe her.
Guck, der hat das gleiche Gehäuse wie ich.
Bei ihm geht das Gehäuse bis hier, bei mir geht das Gehäuse bis zur Wand.
Also der hat ein bisschen mehr Platz, der Gute.
... für Post-Open Frame.
So, I assemble this myself.
It took about three hours to put together.
It's super heavy and super solid.
Super heavy and super solid.
It has an additional 6U that I can expand for later.
Plus, I might downsize a few things, but we'll get into that later.
USV, Storage.
It's great to work on.
It's very open.
Der soll mal zeigen, was was ist.
Das würde mich mal interessieren.
Weil es sieht für mich übelst overkill aus für daheim.
At some point I might figure out how to add some panels and maybe add a door to it.
But I'll figure that out later.
And if not, I'll just try to find one.
Was hat denn der für einen Rack?
Das finde ich, sieht auch total ähnlich wie mein Rack.
Ist das verlinkt?
Ah, das.
Ne, das ist ein anderes.
Rollen.
Rollen ist...
Eigentlich sind Rollen gar nicht so doof für einen Rack, wenn man es mal versteht.
Aber ich mach die Rollen dran.
Das Beste ist immer noch das Ikea-Rack.
Einfach einen Ikea-Schrank und das Zeug reinschieben.
Was das musst du dir anschauen.
Angst vor 5G-Netz.
Oh ne, nicht schon wieder.
Soll ich das wirklich angucken?
Da krieg ich wieder Ausschlag, wenn ich irgendwelche 5G-Verursachtkrebs oder so sehe.
Moment, was für ein Hersteller?
Triplight hab ich noch nie gehört.
Als USV-Anschaltung.
Das ist richtig keckweh.
Okay, können wir uns gleich angucken.
Ja, das ist übrigens auch, was ich bei USVs immer sage.
Es ist bei USVs gar nicht so wichtig, dass die irgendwie möglichst lange das ganze im Heimbereich, möglichst lange überbrücken.
Es reicht, wenn die USV 1-2 Minuten hält.
Also sagen wir mal, 5 Minuten hält, dass man genug Zeit hat, die Systeme runterzufahren.
Das ist eigentlich das Wichtige im Heimbereich.
Also man muss da keine Stunde überbrücken oder so ein Plötzchen.
Brownouts?
Wann hat man denn Brownouts?
Ami-Stromnetz wahrscheinlich.
Spannung fällt ab.
Ja, ja, ich weiß.
Aber sowas hat man eigentlich nie gefühlt.
Also mir ist nicht bewusst, dass ich hier in letzter Zeit mal einen Brownout hatte.
Aber bei den Amis weiß man ja nie so genau.
Ah, hier.
Das weiß man, was es ist.
DS-46.
Ja, sehr gut.
So, das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.
Ja, Stufe 2. Oh, danke schön. Stufe 2 Subscription, das ist ja schon hier.
Excellent, Massive Brain Subscription, danke schön.
AW-Som.
Mehr ist wahrscheinlich, mehr brauchen wir wahrscheinlich nicht. Das wird er wahrscheinlich nie voll kriegen.
Ah, aktuell.
Ja.
Aber SAS SATA Adapters gibt es ja in allen, in alle Richtungen.
Du musst nur aufpassen, dass es von SAS zu SATA geht, aber von SATA zu SAS geht meines Wissens dann nicht.
Oder vielleicht gibt es da mittlerweile auch schon irgendwelche Magic-Dinge, aber...
Also von SAS zu SATA geht, aber mir ist nichts bekannt, dass wir von SATA zu SAS machen.
So, das ist mein Dell R710 Server.
Aha. Ja, wollte ich gerade sagen, das sieht auch gebraucht aus.
Amazon.
Und da oben drüber, das ist 100 Pro, eine GenPro-Gehäuse, das gleiche GenPro-Gehäuse, was ich auch habe. Das sieht so ähnlich aus.
Und dann putte ich es zusammen und hoffe, dass es alles funktioniert.
Also ja, ich habe es auf Amazon gekauft.
Und es funktioniert fantastisch.
Aber anyways, ja, es ist fast maxed out.
Also es hat Dual Xeon X5670s und es sind 2,93 Gigahertz.
Also hat jeder Xeon sechs Cores plus Hyper-Threading.
Also das sind 24 logische Cores.
Also du bekommst 12 physische und 12 virtuell.
Bei gebrauchter Server-Hardware kommt einem eine Sache mittlerweile richtig zugute,
dass sich Hardware-mäßig die letzten Jahre nicht mehr allzu viel tut.
Also sprich, wenn man sich jetzt einen drei Jahre alten Server-Hardware günstig auf Ebay kauft,
die sind leistungsmäßig immer noch ziemlich gut mit dabei.
Also man kann sich ohne Probleme gebrauchte Server-Hardware kaufen mittlerweile,
wenn man mit dem Stromverbrauch klar kommt.
Umso älter der Kram ist, umso mehr verbraucht das halt Strom.
Und generell sind die Server-Dinger hier für RZ-Betrieb ausgelegt, nicht für Stromsparsamkeit.
Ja, es wäre gestern hochgeladen worden.
Ja, ich hatte heute sogar vor, abwechselnd mal wieder ein neues Video hochzuladen.
Aber umso länger ich hier am rumströme.
Und nachher noch mal weiter, wo wir nachher weiterprogrammieren, wird das wahrscheinlich heute eher nix.
Aber mal gucken, mal gucken, vielleicht krieg ich es ja noch gebacken.
DL-380, G8, ja.
Ich kenne die DL-380 noch seit den ersten Generationen.
Die Dinger waren damals auch schon bei uns immer recht beliebt im RZ.
Vor allem weil Dell, äh nicht Dell HP,
weil HP auch immer nicht so einen großen Akt gemacht hat, was Hardware angeht als IBM.
4 Gigs of Registered ECC RAM, so that's pretty much...
Moment, wie war das nochmal mit der Remote-Schnittstelle?
Ähm...
ELO ist die Remote-Schnittstelle von HP, ne?
ELO.
Oder war das IBM?
RSA? RSA ist IBM, ELO ist HP?
Und Dell habe ich vergessen.
Maxed out.
And then in here, it also came with 6...
iTrack ist, genau, genau.
iTrack.
iTrack ist, äh, iDrack.
Ist Dell, ja, richtig.
Jetzt wo ich lese.
Raid 10.
Also sprich, der hat, äh, das hier gemirrored und dann, äh, das hier gestripen, das nochmal gemirrored,
oder besser gesagt, oder umgedreht, oder das hier gestripen, das hier gestripen, das hier gemirrored.
Kein schlechtes.
Wenn man 6 festplatten hat, kann man gut machen.
So that gives me a stripe plus parity.
In all...
Er hätte, er hätte auch, er hätte auch, ein Raid 50 machen können, er hätte, er hätte auch, ein Raid 5 machen können, Raid 5 und ein Mirrored, was total bescheuert wär für die Ausbeute der Platten, ja, aber...
Einfach nur weil es geht.
Dann könnte ich nämlich sagen, ich hab ein Raid 50 daheim.
Nicht sinnvoll, aber, aber es geht.
All of this SSD storage is for my virtual machines.
Oh, and also, this right here, this is not the optical drive.
So if you press the...
Press this button, it's not gonna work.
So the optical drive used to be there.
And I found this really awesome...
Wahrscheinlich hat er eine SSD dahinter gemacht.
Ja, ja, das ist auch bei dem, bei dem Server-Mainboard hier, die haben auch einen IPMI, ähm, nee, nicht, kein IPMI, irgendein, irgend so ein low-budget-management-Interface, das braucht auch noch Java, das ist totaler Rotz, das, da ist die iDrag-Geschichte bei IBM, äh, bei, bei Dell mit den neuesten Firmwaren ganz gut, die machen, äh, HTML5.
Die brauchen kein Java mehr.
Raid 0.
Kamikaze-Raid.
Moin.
X-Jählermann.
Der hat da bestimmt eine SSD dahinter gemacht.
...that you can replace your optical drive and put in another solid-state drive.
That's the drive that runs the OS, which...
Das ist ne coole Sache.
So, if you have a server...
Prog, prog, okay, da macht der noch Virtualisierungs-Action drauf.
...and you have an optical drive and you aren't using it, I highly recommend getting a caddy...
Ich bin mit Prog-Smogs nicht warm geworden.
...und putting in another hard drive.
Hab's ein paar mal ausprobiert, haben wir auch hier im Stream ausprobiert.
An sich ist es ne coole Sache, gerade die Integration mit ZFS und das einfache Handling halt von 4Ms ist cool.
Aber ich bin halt mittlerweile auf so nem Stand, wo ich sag, ey, ich will möglichst wenig, was mir da an die Quere kommt.
Und dementsprechend hab ich jetzt einfach, ähm, mittlerweile auch im Heimbereich nur noch nen Ubuntu-Server drauf.
Auf der Arbeit haben wir ja nur noch überall Red Hat, wobei, ohne Lizenz, ja, also irgendein CentOS-Verschnitt.
Ähm.
Bei meinen Sachen mach ich immer Ubuntu-Server drauf und dann kommt dort das drauf, was ich brauch und nicht mehr.
Also ich mach da ein paar Docker-Containers drauf, vielleicht ein paar LXC-Geschichten von Hand, vielleicht mal ne KVM-VM, fertig.
Und was ich bei Prog-Smogs doof find, ist, dass du da halt diese Prog-Smogs-Container-Lösungen hast.
Dass du da keine Docker-Containers direkt drauf starten kannst.
Wobei, Dockers-Container direkt drauf starten kann.
Ohne Option ist auch doof.
Na klar, man kann ne VM machen für Containers.
Aber ich find's viel angenehmer, so wie's jetzt ist.
Kiste, Low-Budget, Low-Energy, Intel, äh, Quad-Core-Kiste, die hier steht.
Ubuntu-Server draufgeklatscht.
Ähm, Docker-Compose, YAML-File und fertig.
Fünf, fünf Container, oder fünf, sechs Container mit Services.
Automatische Let's Encrypt-Zertifikate und es funktioniert einfach.
Man darf bloß nicht den Fehler machen.
Die Version auf Latest zu setzen.
Weil dann macht er, macht das Auto-Update ab und zu die, äh, Containers kaputt.
Weil irgendwas nicht mehr stimmt.
Sondern man macht einfach die letzte Major-Version rein oder sowas.
Und dann hat man da keine Probleme.
Das einzige, was mir letztens abgekackt ist, war...
Doch, mein Doku-Wiki ist letztens verreckt.
Das Doku-Wiki ist letztens verreckt, weil die Version, weil ne neue Version rausgekommen ist.
Und ich hatte Latest drinstehen.
Und wenn du Latest drinstehen hast und automatisch deine Container updatest,
macht er halt auch wirklich Latest und dann kam dann mit der Config von der alten Version nicht mehr klar.
Man kann unter Proxmox in dem LXC auch Docker machen.
Also sprich, du machst einen LXC-Container und in dem machst du dann Docker.
Klar, kannst du auch machen.
Also sprich, du machst, ähm, Container in Container.
Was nicht wirklich so ist, muss man sagen.
Ähm, Container ist ja eh ein ziemlich doofes Wort.
Im Prinzip ist ja, Container hört sich immer so an, als wäre es ein Lightweight-VM.
Ist es ja gar nicht.
Ein Container ist ja im Prinzip nichts anderes, wie ein stinknormaler Prozess,
der läuft unter Linux, mit ein bisschen, äh, Sandbox-Geschichten drumherum.
Also ein normaler Prozess und ein im Container gestarteten Prozess ist eigentlich kein Unterschied.
Außer, dass ein bisschen mehr, ähm, Isolationsgeschichten dabei sind.
Container unter Linux ist ja eigentlich nur ein normaler Prozess mit Cgroups und Namespaces.
Also...
Cgroups ist für alles, was...
Berechtigungen braucht und, und Ressourcenmanagement zum Beispiel.
Dieser Prozess darf nur, äh, maximal zwei Gigabyte RAM, ein CPU-Core verwenden.
Das ist Cgroups und Namespaces ist das, wo man zum Beispiel User umbiegen kann,
Mountpoints umbiegen kann und sonst was.
Aber im Prinzip ist im Container gestarteten Prozess ein ganz normaler Prozess unter Linux.
Also eigentlich überhaupt kein Unterschied.
Deswegen ist es wahrscheinlich auch kein Problem, wenn ich einen Container starte und in diesem Container einen Container starte.
Weil das unter der Haube gar keinen Unterschied macht, ob ich zwei Container starte oder einen Container im Container starte.
Weil beides ein normaler Prozess im Host-Kernel ist.
Ja, genau.
Man konnte mir glaube ich jetzt nicht so ganz folgen, aber...
Musste mal gesagt werden.
Bin von ESX zu Proxmox gewechselt wegen LXC, das ist echt super, das entspannt schnell.
Okay, aber das ist ja auch was komplett anderes, ne?
Der ESX ist ja gar nicht dafür...
Ich mein, du hättest ja auch eine ESX-VM machen können und darauf LXC laufen.
Okay, also wo ist er denn gerade dabei?
Also dieser Dell-Server kam auch mit dem iDRAC, dem integrierten Dell Remote Access Controller.
Und das ermöglicht mir, damit zu verbinden, wenn es geschlossen ist.
Das ermöglicht mir, die Firmware zu flashen.
Und ich kann sogar die OS auch mit dem ISO verbinden.
Aber ich verwende es nicht so oft.
Aber es ist schön, dass du es kennst.
Und ich kann es verwenden, wenn ich es brauche.
Also das kam mit einem Quad-Gigabit-NIC.
Aber ich habe es auch installiert.
Und die meiste dieser Hardware ist den Gästen durchgeführt worden.
Okay, nächstes Mal...
Ja, ja.
Das ist eindeutig das gleiche Gehäuse.
Eindeutig das gleiche Gehäuse.
Wir haben eindeutig das gleiche Gehäuse.
Siehst du?
Chenbro-Gehäuse.
Auch gute Idee.
Eigentlich auch eine gute Idee, seinen euren Desktop-Rechner da einzubauen.
Kann man, glaube ich, abmachen hätten.
Es ist super duper breit.
Aber ich habe Front-Panel-Axis zu Buttons.
Hat einige blinkende Lichter.
USB.
Alle normalen Sachen, die man auf einem PC-Gehäuse sieht.
Es hat auch einen Fan hier und einen Filter, den ich reinigen kann.
Das Gehäuse ist relativ modular.
Und was ich an dem cool finde, das ist eines der wenigen Server-Gehäuse, die einen Staubfilter
drin hat und sowas.
Die meisten haben das ja nicht.
Ist ja auch nicht sinnvoll im RZ.
Ist ja anderweitig.
Denen geht die Klimaanlage durch oder sonst was.
Du brauchst ja normalerweise keinen Staubfilter.
Im Server selbst.
Aber der hat welche und das ist ganz praktisch.
Was Pflanze400 fragt.
Warum sind eigentlich Techniker-Einsätze bei Hoster pro 15 Minuten immer so teuer?
29 Euro.
Nein, 29 Euro ist doch nicht teuer.
Ich meine, der Typ, der bekommt einen Auftrag.
Der muss erst mal verstehen, was er machen muss.
Den muss ich vielleicht ein paar Teile holen.
Muss rüberlaufen.
In der Zeit macht er nichts anderes.
Und wieder zurück.
Das sind doch 29 Euro vollkommen in Ordnung.
Und wenn es einfach nur Hardware tauschen.
Jetzt kriegt er das ja in der Viertelstunde.
Festplatte rein, raus.
Auch hin.
Das ist doch eigentlich vollkommen okay.
15 Minuten.
29 Euro.
Der muss ja auch was machen.
Vor allem macht er in der Zeit auch nichts anderes.
Ich finde das okay.
Viertelstunde.
30 Euro.
Was hattest du eigentlich damals auf deinem IP Fire laufen?
OpenVPN?
IP Fire habe ich doch schon ewig nicht mehr laufen.
Schon 10 Jahre oder so.
Ewig nicht mehr.
Ich hatte damals OpenVPN.
Ja.
Auf meinem PFSense hatte ich auch OpenVPN laufen.
Mittlerweile würde ich es anders machen.
Mittlerweile würde ich wahrscheinlich WireGuard verwenden.
So, weiter geht's.
Okay, es ist wirklich legit sein alter Gamingrechner.
Es ist legit sein alter Gamingrechner.
Ja, warum nicht?
Es ist ja im Prinzip auch kein Unterschied.
Also der Software ist es ziemlich egal ob sie auf einem Server oder auf einem Desktop
läuft.
Das ist absolut kein Unterschied.
Ja.
Das ist dem Zeug was darauf läuft, vollkommen egal.
Was macht WireGuard denn eine bessere Wahl?
Ich finde die Konfig ist einfacher und die Clients sind besser.
Was kommt diese Hardware her?
Das ist der Corsair Air 540 High Air Flow ATX Cube Case.
Das ist ein super schöner Case.
Ah, erstmal eine fette SRC-Auto.
Sogar ein VM-PCI-Path-Through.
Okay, der macht alles das, was ich auch ursprünglich vorhatte zu machen
und im Nachhinein sich herausgestellt hat,
es ist eigentlich für einen Heimgebrauch vollkommen überflüssig.
Es ist eine coole Sache, das zu machen.
Wie gesagt, ich hatte auch vor,
einen PCI-Path-Through mit meinem Server zu machen, alles.
Ich habe das auch alles ausprobiert und es hat auch alles funktioniert,
aber unterm Strich bin ich dann zu dem Schluss gekommen,
für einen Heimbereich alles total auferseist überflüssig
und bin jetzt bei einer Low-Power, Low-Budget,
Vier-Kern-Intel-Kiste hängen geblieben
mit einer 10-Terabyte-Platte drin, ohne RAID, ohne alles
und einmal nachts in AirSync auf eine externe Platte, fertig.
Das ist noch DDR3, ja.
Und das ist mein zweiter Proxmox-Server.
Mir ging es bei OpenVPN immer auf den Keks,
wenn er alles durchs VPN geroutet hat.
Will man ja meistens gar nicht.
Ich hoffe, ihr habt die Tour meines Home-Labs genossen.
Aber guck mal, wer da ist.
Und solche Spezialisten hast du dann da immer, ja.
Keine Ahnung, ob jetzt hier irgendwie einer dabei ist.
Aber wenn du so Videos machst,
hast du immer so die Besserwisser am Start, immer.
So einer hier zum Beispiel.
Was will er dann hier?
Ja, das schwerste Gerät gehört immer nach ganz unten ins Rack,
aber ist vielleicht Geschmackssache, weiß ja nicht,
mache erst 25 Jahre eigentlich...
What the... Was will er überhaupt?
Ich verstehe nicht mal...
Und am besten finde ich die Leute, die als Argument, dass sie recht haben,
sagen, ich mache das schon 25 Jahre.
USV unten, er findet auch, dass USV unten sind.
Und ein LAN-Com ist keine Firewall, das ist ein Router.
Der LAN-Com ersetzt ja hauptsache viel aus.
Was möchte er mir überhaupt sagen?
What the fuck, das hat mit dem Video überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Ich habe nichts von LAN-Com da drinnen.
What the fuck?
Hat er das Video überhaupt gesehen?
Alter, die ganzen Wichtigtour auf YouTube immer...
Er ist bestimmt Consultant, 100 Pro.
100 Pro, dem Bild nach ist der Consultant, garantiert.
Garantiert ist der Consultant da.
Oh, wir sind doch fast 3 Stunden an.
Leute, ich habe Hunger, ich muss essen.
Wir sind heute nicht weit gekommen, ich gebe es zu.
Ich habe viel rumgeschwätzt und wir haben wenig geguckt.
Aber ich hoffe, es hat euch trotzdem gefallen.
Ich bookmark mir den Krempel mal.
Übrigens hier, krasser Windows-Hack.
Ich habe es nicht gesehen.
Alle Tabs markieren und dann sagen, bookmark all Tabs.
Session, 30.08, save.
Und jetzt, guckt mal hier, 30.08, alle Tabs, die wir vom letzten Mal noch offen hatten.
Ja, ich habe das schon mehrfach gespeichert.
Geht mit Ctrl-D auch?
Ja, kann sein.
Aber das ist sehr nice, ja.
Chrome Hack, excellent.
Das heißt, das nächste Mal, ich kann das jetzt hier zumachen, das heißt, das nächste Mal kann ich ja einfach sagen, okay, Session, 28, New Folder, ups, äh, 28, New Folder, öffnen, zack, und schon haben wir wieder alles von heute auf, können weiter gucken, exzellent, wahrlich exzellent.
So, Leute, man kann übrigens mehrere Tabs auch anklicken und refreshen, ich geh jetzt was essen, übelst Hunger, weil vorher, um genau zu sein, geh ich vorher mal, geh ich mal aufs Klo, ähm, das wolltet ihr wahrscheinlich unbedingt im Detail wissen, und dann geh ich was essen, übrigens, ich hab gesehen, ich hab nen Sub gegiftet bekommen für Games Done Quick, äh, Dankeschön, von, was, Space Jam, warum auch immer, also, ich das bekommen hab, aber, nice, falls das hier im Stream war, weil das noch nicht lange her,
warum auch immer ich nen Sub gegiftet für, bekommen hab für was, was ich eh so gut wie nicht gucke, aber, exzellent, bist du noch Poki-Sub, Moment, bin ich noch Poki-Sub, Poki-W, Poki-W, nein, ich bin kein Poki-Sub mehr, Virgin-Check, Poki-W, also, Leute, ähm, macht's gut, bis später, wahrscheinlich machen wir gegen Nachmittag, also, bisschen, ganze Ecke später Nachmittag, programmieren wir den ESP32 weiter.
Bis dann, macht's gut, tschüss.
Tschüssi.